[Music]
oh
pap
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
ahahahahahahahahah
oh
[Music]
yeah
w
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar's going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
Pawn One move checkm two seconds oh oh
my God why an arm get
in it's been dramatic dream runs for
some heart breaks for others a we
expecting more twists and turns I'd say
heck yes welcome everyone to the chassa
Masters I'm International Master T sa
alongside me as always my good friends
grandmas Robert H and grandmas David H
guys we're in for another big day of
chess four players facing elimination
two will be knocked out and a big big
Winner's final David are you hyped I
can't wait Tanya it feels like it's all
been building up to this um of course uh
still so much to play for we've had the
underdog stories we've had Magnus Carson
in action uh what more could we ask for
it's been simply great so far and I'm
expecting more of the same Robert how
excited are you for today oh I'm popped
and I've never heard David get that loud
before so I can tell that he is ready
for an excellent day of Chess
ahead it is going to be more drama on
the board as we got big matches coming
up four heavy weights in the losers
bracket have to F fight it out they're
on their last life these are the
brackets going into our big Winners
final coming later today we started with
eight players in the winner semi-final
we saw Denis lazovic take down Jose
Martinez Magnus car in a dramatic
Armageddon one against Vladimir fedos
they'll be facing each other in the big
Winners final it is the 17-year-old
Dennis lazic the kid who's been on a
dream run against the biggest hurdle the
world number one Magnus but we start the
day with the losers bracket players on
their last live it will be Vladimir fedf
taking on Yan neesi and Jose Martinez
who has been playing Amazing chess in
the chessable Masters winning the play G
but yesterday he lost to Dennis he will
be on his last life up against Ali RZA
fuja who knocked out Wesley so
predictions guys who are we expecting
Robert to make it through to the loser
semi-finals you're putting too much
pressure on me because we have for the
second day in a row some Heavy Hitters
in the elimination bracket Ali Raza fua
he survived against Wesley so Wesley
made one incorrect pawn move and that
was that and so for Ali Rea who was on
his last life I think he will be one of
the players to make it through he'll
continue his journey here at the
chesfield Masters David I don't know do
you agree with me or am I just going out
and a limb here I've got to say uh I
trust you Robert always and I do agree
in this regard it feels like uh things
are working on his uh on his side a bit
of luck in his favor and I've got to say
in the other match as well fed has been
on fire really really unlucky against
Magnus Carson yesterday so I'm going to
say that his run might continue I would
love to see rematch
potentially of course uh Four Strong
players hard to predict but those are my
bets we're going to be in for some
awesome chest today really pumped about
it it was an absolute roller coaster
yesterday let's rewind and set the tone
for the action that's coming up take a
look those players in the elimination
bracket now four of the world's best so
there's definitely going to be blood
spiled that was a blunder from Wesley so
and his time in this turnour might be
done this is getting crazy where is the
check bait coming in do you just we
go what a finish that was sick for M
Razer the Knight is coming the king is
coming but a mistake Now by Vash gra
White's pawns are running suddenly
White's ahead Maxim V resigns the Jeep
on is Unstoppable Maxim is eliminated
white king actually going to feel safe
and sound or who apparently there was a
big blunder wa wow double question mark
and black can pretty much win on the
spot it's game over and it's match over
Dennis lazovic advances true I see
progress with a helping hand but
unfortunately again you're playing
Magnus Carson and he is a Marathon Man
whoa Magnus Carson lost on time are you
kidding me and the Rooks come off the
board then the last Pawn drops and
that's immediately a drop Magnus
progresses from this Armageddon so close
so
close and just a few moment minutes to
players we will be ready to go and these
are the win probabilities for our chable
masters Magnus Carlson as always a
massive favorite to win the event Robert
what do you think are we overstating it
a little bit here or is Magnus just
Unstoppable well with magnus's win
probability around 90% I have to say I
think that's accurate the other players
in the elimination bracket some super
strong names but they're on their last
life and Dennis lck he has the same
amount of time left as Magnus Carlson
but when you're facing Magnus perhaps
the greatest player of all time you have
your hands full so I have to say it does
look accurate to me it's hard to bet
against Magnus no matter what the format
is he's always always the big favorite
and yesterday what a match it was
against Vladimir fedel let's take a look
at our po match starts with that big
fight right there David it was a match
that could that could have gone either
way Magnus took the early lead but fos
he really fought back it really went
down to the wire I jinxed Magnus
actually Yesterday by calling him the
marathon man just before he lost on time
in game four but ultimately in the
Armageddon he was able to pick up the
speed pick up the accuracy uh when it
really mattered and look how close it
was there Magnus was critical about his
own play but 93% accuracy not bad at all
and fed not far behind It ultimately
came down to that Armageddon came down
to a rush Against Time and um yeah I
think fed with a bit more luck things
could have gone his way Magnus as he
said yesterday needs to improve today
against Dennis lazic to ensure a victory
and we saw one blunder per side that was
on the board but perhaps the biggest
blunder of all was not included there it
was a loss on time for Magnus Carlson
who said he just didn't feel like he was
in it that he was struggling that he was
fortunate he survived he won that match
so he does have his two lives left a not
in it Magnus is he still the second best
player in the world we got the answer to
that today he plays against Dennis lazic
Dennis has been so in formed Magnus said
it himself it's like he beat the
murderers Ro what a performance he's had
and that matchup is coming on later
today Magnus Carlson said he needs to do
better today than he did yesterday and
of course there are players who are
fighting on their last life one of them
the two times World Championship
Challenger Yan nepom Nishi he will be
playing against Vladimir FV and
yesterday he had quite a match against
Maxim Vash gra Again David it was Yan
who was on the back foot he lost the
first he lost the first game and then a
dramatic Armageddon saw a big turn
around what did you make of that finish
yeah it was brilliant from Yan again
with with his back against the wall in
must-win situations he really upped his
level and we see it there uh decent
accuracy for both sides but ultimately
decided by those brilliancies from Yan
Nom Nishi in the second game a queen
sacrifice with a Checkmate and in the
Armageddon making the second last
mistake it was Vash de gra who blundered
finally and ultimately Yan progresses so
very close those two Rivals uh we'll see
Vash in future throughout the tour I'm
sure but it's Yan who's Clinging On to
survival and he needs to improve again
today to uh maintain his place here the
chest B
Masters for maxim VRA that was a
heartbreaking moment so close to getting
that Armageddon Victory but it's not
over till it's over in chess and that's
what we saw Yan she stays alive in the
chess Masters we will have the loser
semi-finals today we start with that
later of course Robert we've got a big
matchup coming on with the 17-year-old
Dennis lvic taking on the world number
one now of course Magnus a big favorite
today what does Dennis need to do to
make you think that he's got a chance
against Magnus today well Magnus Carlson
is nearly double the age of his opponent
that's not something that we say very
often but Dennis lck he is a teenage
sensation he's been on a tear and his
ratings throw them out the window except
perhaps that chess.com rapid rating
nearly 2800 up there with the best of
them so I think for Dennis his future is
so bright but his present and his recent
history oh watch out because as Magnus
himself said he took down some of the
very best players in the world he's a
scary guy he's not going to lose without
an absolute
fight well you saw them in Toronto
playing over the board and actually it
was very close Magnus won eventually
against Dennis but Dennis got a draw
there in Toronto and even his defeat
against Magnus was uh just in the final
stages a last minute blunder so
definitely anything
possible we all know Magnus lives
rentree in most of the players heads but
the younger generation tends to fight
that and Dennis lazovic has said he's
got no Heroes he's got no Idols in the
Chess World it's going to be a big fight
Dennis needs to keep that attitude be
Fearless on the board and he's been
quite the Conqueror this chessable
Masters
Robert he's been just a beast I mean
there are no other words to describe his
performance thus far meating some of the
biggest names in chess starting with
Hikaru Nakamura then Anish giri Maxim
vashir lra for good measure and let's
not forget Jose Martinez so Dennis lavic
he's been a kid on a mission and can
that mission continue today it might be
Mission Impossible when against Magnus
Carlson but hey why not the magical run
may continue and he may see his way all
the way to the Grand Final oh my gosh
that could be if that happens it would
be the biggest upset that we've seen in
the Champions Chester the way danis
lavic is playing you cannot write that
one off and of course once again that
will come on later the Dennis versus
Magnus matchup we will start off with
the losers quarterfinals and you
mentioned Jose Martinez he's been having
a great run as well great performance in
the Swiss planes he also started off
well but yesterday against Dennis lawick
in that game one I think it all just
turned around for Jose losing a winning
position it sees him in the losers
bracket and he takes on Ali Resa fuja
David on paper Ali RZA has got to be a
favorite where do you see Jose's
chances on paper fuia is the favorite
but uh Jose Martinez just needs to
channel that form we've seen throughout
the last few days from him yes there was
a blip yesterday it felt like Martinez
was trying a bit too hard against laic
but um if he maintains that form if he
kind of regains his balance he's got a
chance fua who we see in front of us now
has been up and down missed an
inconsistent sparkling world class play
on his day but also a few blunders here
in there so Jose has to hope that he
catches fua uh on an off day a bit off
guard maybe in a quieter position where
fara's strengths aren't allowed to
shine Ali Resa fua lost to Vladimir FV
went down to the losers bracket and then
eliminated one of the best in the world
eliminated Wesley so there's definitely
going to be a big fight between these
two Jose Martinez he's flexing a little
bit right now on the camera stretching
getting ready uh body language what do
you make of Ali Resa he looks very
focused David looks focused and I think
he's extremely determined uh to put that
inconsistent form behind him and uh in
the meantime the others other a
quarterfinal Vladimir fed against yan
neomi yan slightly older but so level
there in terms of ratings and uh maybe
that head-to-head Robert just uh
slightly in Yan's favor uh giving him
the upper hand it does surpris me yon is
the higher rated between the two at
least over the board but as you look at
their ratings online they're almost
identical 2812 for the big fish 2011 for
Yan napesi so this is a very close call
between two great players two players
who can win this whole thing despite
being in the losers bracket and we saw
how close both of them have been and
yand pomi he was out just on the verge
of being eliminated against Maxi V sh gr
and one Hasty king move allow Yan the
two-time world championship Challenger
to survive and he didn't just survive he
Advanced and I'm telling you don't count
him out because he can beat anyone in
this field including his former world
Champion rival Magnus
Carlson not many players in the world
can boast about winning the candidates
twice back you back the two times World
Championship challenge as you mentioned
it is all about him finding his form
finding his rhythm and yesterday the way
he checkm it Maxim Vash lrav in that
second game it feels like he has
ultimately found it but the Armageddon
was a bit up and down for fet it just
feels that he's been more consistent
than Yan is that fair to say Robert that
so far FV has been the more consistent
player well the reason I like this
matchup is they kind of have the similar
style as when they're on their best game
they just Crush their opponents but
sometimes they get a little bit too
feisty they just want that Victory they
play aggressive tactical Styles and I
mean for fedos he was really close to
beating Magnus Carlson but a day before
that against Ali Rea fua he probably
should have lost that if you repeated
that game 10 times I think he loses nine
out of the 10 but that one was good
enough fping down two full
pawns and we often talk about styles of
players David Robert saying that these
two have a similar style how do we
expect the opening how important will it
be for these players the opening
approach that they bring on and what are
you
expecting uh I'm expecting the Catalan
opening because yanomi is wearing his
Barcelona Football
top but fed save is the one who starts
with white uh of course he can freestyle
he plays every first move pretty much um
he has this really unique style Magnus
mentioned it Robert you highlighted it
there and I think Yan there we go Pawn
to D4 if Yan brings his world
championship repertoire he will be in
good stad here we see the nimzo Indian
defense blacks Bishop coming out to pin
the White Knight early fed have used
this move Queen to C2 yesterday against
Magnus Carson we see a quick trade and
uh White has the bishop pair but black
Ahad in development uh a lot of theory
here Tanya you're a D4 player uh must
have seen this position at some point
yes and I like these positions with
black uh and also let's remind everyone
before we Deep dive into the ideas that
this is a best of two so the margin for
error is so little you have to keep
things under control take calculated
risk because to come back is never easy
with such few matches and there we see
after 86 one set of minor pieces has
been traded off white of course had the
option to even fall back with the bishop
but going for a more direct approach
here Knight to F3 and Robert he Yan
slows down before capturing on
C4 does that surprise you well I think
it's what we've been talking about the
margins are thin here with a just two
game matches if you make one slip in the
opening and give Vladimir fedos of the
advantage you may not come back from it
and look at this queen on C5 what an
annoying piece to deal with it's just
sitting here saying you can't touch your
B Pawn to develop your Bishop f kto it
because your knight is loose you can't
easily move the Knight because the C7
Pawn is behind it all the while your
protecting your Pawn on D4 so Yan he's
got his face in his hands right now
David have you seen this queen C5 idea
before and has Yan is the more important
question uh I must admit I'm not too
familiar with this queen C5 move as far
as I was the uh dropping back the queen
to C3 was the main move uh in that
position that's appeared in multiple uh
Master games the whole idea is firstly
as you mentioned to keep pressure on
this Black Knight but also to clamp down
to stop black breaking out with E5 and
that has very much been set up now with
this last move Black's Rook activating
he's pretty much guaranteeing yand pishi
that he wants to throw that E Pawn
forward to develop the black Bishop just
to open lines towards the white king
while it's still stuck in the center and
um yeah certainly Yan naishi was
surprised I believe a rare move but uh
after recomposing himself correctly just
improving a piece correctly setting up a
threat and I'm equally surprised to see
feder SEF think now because if this was
prepared if this was home cooking as we
say queen to C5 something he studied
before then surely he would have
examined what to do after Black's most
natural move Rook to E8 and there we go
Knight into E5 blocking Black's main
idea it's pretty much uh one side saying
what they want to do next and feder
shutting the door in his face um what do
you make of this Knight exchange now uh
Robert this is uh changing the pawn
structure changing the dynamic of the
game well white has these double pawns
that may seem bad but white just has
more active pieces despite the fact that
the king remains in the center so black
offers a queen trade white will likely
bring a rook on a semi-open line it's
about developing these pieces on the
king side that can't get out so Tanya
you at first glance I don't love double
pawns but I like activity open files
what do you make of this position
because the engine off to the side of
the board here says it's pretty level
would you rather have white or black in
this setup I started earlier I do like
these lines with the black pieces in the
nimzo and I think the main idea for
black was to get E5 in which now has
been stopped at the cost of these double
bonds but while white has been doing
that it allows black to finish
development for example all right he's
taking on C5 I was thinking of ideas of
actually sacrificing on C7 with white
King still in the center maybe we'll see
that because the main problem in this
position for black is to develop that
light Square Bishop that is the absolute
key and very often in these structures
you can even give up the C7 Pawn open up
the C line to do just that for
development for example a move like B6
comes to my mind or you're highlighting
the move Bishop B D7 which the more I
see I like that one as well the main
point is that if white was to get greedy
with the C7 Pawn your entire King side
is still in the house you haven't moved
a single piece black can quickly take
out the bishop can bring the Rook to the
open line and very often that gives more
than enough compensation for the
pawn I'm with you I think that's a
viable option whether you play B6 or
Bishop D7 Yan he's sitting in for
another think because this is a critical
moment sometimes when we review games
David we quickly just press the next
button just go through it but this could
be a game-changing moment whether he
sacrifices the pawn or plays rookie 7
I'm going to ask you the question David
knowing your answer you love material so
I'm assuming you'd play a move like Rook
E7 or Pawn to C6 here to keep that pawn
you know me too well Robert I wouldn't
hesitate I would keep that black porn on
the board but I'm not yanomi um I know
him very well and I think his Instinct
uh he's mulling it over now his instinct
is to sacrifice to play actively
dynamically all of these top players is
they want to play the most ambitious
move they don't want to just sit there
passively defend let their opponent
dictate the pace of the game to have the
upper hand to have more fun um so I
agree with Tanya Yan is definitely
considering it um he's no you know he's
not a timid scaredy cat like me but oh I
jinx it there we go Rooks E7 he is a two
cat
L defending the pawn and black is
passive I think Yan just made this move
for you David he knows you're
commentating on it this is your St while
he's playing according to to what you
want him to do right now but it also
makes a lot of sense because again white
is so far behind in development that
black perhaps has the time to do it but
this is what I was afraid of because now
anytime you move the B Pawn which he's
done it white can perhaps put the bishop
on G2 for example right now itself you
can take the Rook on C5 white will
capture The Rook on A8 Black's the one
with the double pawns the bishop still
on C8 I'm just wondering who does this
trade favor Robert yeah this would
definitely favor white I know we were
seeing how White's double pawns at
Center weren't so bad those double
isolated pawns for black would have been
awful so Rook B8 I think that's the
proper response this Rook now has to
slide back as it's under attack and that
does give black the time to push this
backwards Pawn or trade off the light
Square Bishops I actually think that Yan
is handling this perfectly there could
still be some sort of attacking chances
on the king side if Jon isn't careful
eventually a rook sliding to G1 and pawn
to G5 but so far everything looks fine
in Black's position it's about
developing trading off key pieces and
speaking of Rook D7 David that is an
excellent move I was thinking Bishop to
B7 but he says your best piece is
actually your Rook rather than your
Bishop staring Into Thin Air love moves
like Rook to D7 despite the fact that
you move the same piece numerous
times Rooks become the most powerful
pieces often in the end game it's all
about open lines open files and that
open D line for the white Rook uh was
already uh to be utilized and now just
neutralizing the opponent's piece I
wouldn't be surprised to see the black
king step towards the center as well in
the next few turns just to again
challenge there we go King to fa to
control those key entry squares the
white Rook wants to enter wants to cre
into the black camp but the black king
is going to shut the door and white was
kind of obliged there to Castle himself
the white king now not too happy stuck
on one of the flanks Kings want to be in
the center it's easier to of Direction
switch up uh Direction later
but it was more important to connect the
Rooks so um I've got to say this is
going in Black's favor on the camera you
can't really tell who the happier player
is but
fed I fear for him here long term if all
the Rooks disappear black is simply
going to win Black's Queen side porns
those three versus two uh on that Left
Flank they're going to March forward and
uh we talked about double pawns earlier
Tanya why is kingside majority far
harder to utilize that's really well put
that if all the pieces are traded and
it's a pure King Pawn ending black is
essentially a pawn up it's so much
easier for black to create a passer is
just a winning end game so white needs
to be careful to me Robert it looks like
it might be time for white to start
thinking about a Pawn rooll on the king
side that's why you had the majority
you're already thinking about pushing
that F Pawn pushing that H Pawn get F4
F5 in because if you don't do anything
then David's idea of trading pieces
could become a big reality while FV has
a think in this position Robert update
us with what is happening on the other
big matchup between alza and Jose again
two players on their last lives yeah
this game it's deep into the end ending
where both sides are trying to stop the
other's plans and here on the right hand
side of our screen we see that Jose
Martinez with the white pieces against
aliv zaa it's a pretty level game with
white having a knight versus a black
Bishop so as I look across these matches
so far there's been little separation
between these players and I I just think
that it's a pretty balanced
Affair looks pretty much symmetrical the
pawn structure here um I'm looking at
the cameras as well both look pretty
calm feels like Jose Martinez doesn't
want to take any risk here with white um
it's after all as you mentioned Tanya a
two game match losing with white would
be a cardinal in here you cannot get
away with it um then again the Symmetry
we talked about open lines white is the
one with slightly more active pieces
White's Queen more active than its
counterpart and white occupying the only
open Line uh the E file so question mark
attached to this last move Tanya can you
see any specific reasons or um what why
could that be a mistake to me it looks
like such a natural move because you
want to make sure your Queen's free to
move around a little bit your D pawns
protected Rook d8 would be a move that
we'd all want to make in this position
you put put the Rook on a nice Square
it's actually doing something there but
I think here are the Eternal question
and I'm going to throw it to both of you
here it's Knights versus Bishop in these
kind of position what do we prefer do we
prefer the Knight or do we prefer the
Bishop Robert I'm going to startop with
you well the bishop is kind of biting on
granite with this Pawn chain here is
Right In The Bishop's path so there's no
good useful diagonal to work with Knight
E5 that wasn't the move so I think we
should analyze just bring up the
analysis board for a second because this
move gets an X I'm going to look and see
what was the Improvement ever so quickly
and it says that B4 that's why Rook d8
earned a question mark is that white
should try to Spring free a pass Pawn if
black were to take on B4 now we see how
clear it is that pawn will push a rook
trade at some point will help white uh
clear the road for that pass Pawn so
this I wouldn't really consider it a you
know a huge mistake from White it's hard
to spot these ideas and it creates
weaknesses but David now that we see it
grinding like a grandmas it could have
been a good start by pushing some of
these outside pawns yeah B4 would have
been a really instructive really classy
move switching Focus there um with black
off balance suddenly playing on the
queen side but very hard to see as you
say probably the most difficult thing in
chess is knowing when to kind of go for
these exchanges when to change the
structure uh when to start taking action
when it looks like you you can just
slowly maneuver and improve and I did
prefer the queen and Knight combo over
the queen and Bishop the Knight is the
only piece that can act in a way a queen
cannot so Queen and Knight together um
do often work wonders but now that the
bishop and Knight have both disappeared
fewer imbalances here white is only
playing with one kind of small uh kind
of aesthetic Advantage at least that's
the open file but if Quin disappear I
don't think you can really profit from
uh that small thing so um yeah the
problem for Jose Martinez he wants to
kind of drop the White Queen back kind
of set up a battery along the E file but
there is a white hanging Pawn on A4 so
he's kind of tied down um Tanya Queen
exchange like Robert said I love to
grind like a Grandmaster in an end game
to push to try to look for these small
advantages but I'm struggling to see any
I'm going to first ask the burning
question who came up with the name grind
like a
grandm I can uh give away a little trade
secret it was originally the title was
meant to be grind like gelfand because
uh when I was young he grounded me down
in some long Seven Hour end games he did
the same to Magnus a few times but
in the end grind like a grandm was a bit
more catchy so uh GLG that's what we
call it I love it and we keep alluding
to that book that you co-authored with
Magnus Carlson and I think we might be
seeing another grind coming out in this
now even if the queens were to get
traded would it completely be leveled
because I see one open file white has
total control of it the Rook from E5 can
give a check and maybe start targeting
the queenside pawn it looks like the
black Rook even if the Queens are traded
off off will be more passive at least
for a while and Robert's idea of
eventually getting B4 in white might be
the first one to create a passer even if
it's an end game I think White's got
something to play for here
David certainly um you never give up
that's the kind of 101 of the grind uh
it's like in life I'm sure all the
viewers at home sometimes you have to
work a bit harder you have to work
overtime at the office you have to kind
of really dig deep even when you're not
feeling it too much you have to find the
energy from somewhere that's what Jose
Martinez has to do right now like you
say Tanya Queen exchange whoa I was
about to say was inevitable take the
Queens off and then try to look for
small advantages White's King coming to
the center instead he gambits a pawn
Robert I was saying earlier this was
pretty much impossible should black just
snack on that straggler on A4 Jose
raising his eyebrows there do you think
he missed it is this intentional it's
intentional and it's kind of what you
were hinting at earlier that these
players they will give up material if it
means that they get active play so just
to put this sample line on the board and
ala he doesn't have to take the pawn
although I think that White's intentions
are clear if Queen takes Pawn on A4 if
we can just show this quickly The Rook
comes up to E7 and now we see the White
Queen joining C7 is loose if you try to
protect this Pawn by just pushing it to
safety you can already see that the
black queen is out of play and white can
even play Alpha zero style to try and
get after the black king so the engine
doesn't seem phased it says that black
can snack on that pawn but I would
personally a little bit worried with
having my queen offside like this even
if it's objective equality I think
practically speaking Tanya it does seem
like white has a little bit more fun the
a pawn not so relevant just yet it's a
really nice Point made by you you
sacrifice a pawn for activity and it
really feels like Jose's style as well
to get into these kind of positions but
it's also Ali rza's style he picks it up
because white was in any case planning
to go Rook e 7 a difficult threat to
fight and now this is going to be quite
the fireworks on the board unexpectedly
so over the last few moves it looked
like a very slow position it's blowing
up the queen from E2 is going to step
onto F3 start targeting the F7 Pawn
right now black needs to answer the most
immediate question how are you defending
C7 the first move that came to my mind
was slip up with a rook to D7 you want
to challenge that Rook on the seventh
rank but I think that's dangerous
because then white can give a check on
E8 you come up with your king to G7
Queen E5 and suddenly we see that the
only only move black will have is F6 and
I think David with Rook E7 check it just
felt like it would be too dangerous for
white so instead we've got the move C5
and my question to you is can white go
Queen to F3 ignore the center while he
answers it he wants to take on the C5
Pawn
instead he actually preferred your move
there Tanya I think he might well try it
now on the next turn there we go still
this Checkmate in two threat uh the F7
Pawn is hit needs to be defended and uh
fua notice how he's going passive here
out of necessity I talk about divorce
here with the black king The Black Queen
they're so far apart from each other and
that spells trouble so you often have to
put a piece passive just while the queen
is absent from the defense and here we
go equal material yet again the pawn has
been snapped off but things are
disappearing I think F has calculated
really really well that he can liquidate
the whole Queens side that all those
queenside pawns will just fall off the
board and uh why is he hesitating surely
he's going to push that a PA now maybe
he's just slightly afraid that the white
will zoom over and uh prevent that pawn
from continuing its Advance still I
don't know Robert I would slightly
prefer white in this position I
definitely would prefer to have the
white side of this position just because
white has the activity so I have to say
both players playing a nearly perfect
game uh Jose he went for the activity
there were some practical problems that
still need to be solved from the black
side but I think that there we go I was
about to say one little precise move
away from Full equality for Ali Raza the
the queen protects the pawn it also
protects the king side this F7 Pawn
which has been a weak point and puts
pressure on the C3 Pawn so I do think in
the near future we'll just see pieces as
you would say David hoovered off the
board and we are likely to see a split
point so Tanya I mean it's been a fun
game in this one but I just I get the
sense that the life is kind of sucked
out of it although Alpha zero style play
on the king side Jose is not going to
let this game fizzle out without more of
a fight I agree but I think black can
just simply stop that Alpha Zer esque
plan of H5 with pushing his own Pawn up
the board and after that I just see a
symmetrical Pawn structure black playing
H5 here seems to stop all uh White's
dreams on the king side eventually I'm
uh for seeing the a pawn being traded
off for the C Pawn can we say that draw
is not too far away in this
one looks that way I think a draw is
almost inevitable and uh maybe we take a
step out and go to The Buzz view because
the other game uh while a draw is still
possible there it's heating up it's a
pawn race it's only Rooks and pawns left
and suddenly look at that black king on
the left hand board fed against yand
pomi all these King walks we've seen
throughout the tournament so far
throughout division one Black's King has
entered started grabbing pawns and uh
temporarily black is a pawn ahead
evaluation bar on his side as well um
Robert what do you make of this has fed
have just lost control or was this an
intentional Gamble on his part well he
we got into an end game where those
double pawns were not good and they're
doubled no more because black is up a
Pawn on the left hand side of our screen
so Tanya she said she wanted from the
black side the whole way she thought
that that opening was good for yand
pishi and it's proven to be the case so
Vladimir fedos of this is a rocky start
it hasn't been good from him he is
trying to challenge black on the seventh
rank with his Rook but it it feels like
Yan with precise play and with two
minutes and change on his clock he
should get the job done I think this is
one of those games which is going to
become a model game for the nimzo Indian
Queen C5 a new idea tried but it didn't
really need lead anywhere and I think
the way Yan handled it trying to get the
E5 break in then how he developed the
Queens side Bishops and now look at this
King this Rook Pawn end game they often
say that peace activity the king
activity and The Rook activity in these
kind of end games is worth a pawn here
black already has an extra pawn and Yan
wants to keep as many of those pawns
alive on the king side I see some real
winning chances in this one David what
do you make of it do you think this is
closer to a draw or a Yan
win I just love the way Yan's been
playing I think especially after these
last couple of moves it's uh pretty much
guaranteed to be a win now the black
pawns on the king side four versus two
there they're going to start running um
in the meantime small update the other
game we were following did as predicted
end in a draw uh Queens came off pawns
came off dead equality there so this is
the last game we've got left in the
losers quarterfinal and yeah just Yan I
love that F5 move just a couple of turns
ago just push pawns when in doubt if you
don't know what to do it's the end game
get as close to promotion as possible
and that's what fed's trying to do now
the problem is connected P pawns the
black king is going to shepher his own
pawns forward and Black's Rook is doing
a fantastic job later of just sliding
behind White's runner on the B file um I
think it's a race but black is just too
far ahead even if black were to lose his
Rook for the white B Pawn in in the near
future Black's pawns by then would be
too far down the board so uh this one I
think he's almost got it in the back
he's done the hard work Go Active with
your king everyone in the end game
that's uh how to yeah that's how to stay
on the front foot looks good Robert I
loved this move this latest move King to
G3 I'm sure Pawn takes Pawn on G4 was
also winning but you're already up
material and it's not about grabbing
more pawns it's about pushing them to
the other side so instead of stealing a
Pawn on G4 said let me just push and now
yes he could take this Pawn on H3 after
The Rook takes the pawn he can bring his
King back and then push his passers I
don't see why you would even waste any
time push this one all the way up the
board Jan says all right I I just feel
like it's important to take this one it
doesn't change the Dynamics of the game
it doesn't change the evaluation Tanya
Yan has done everything right in this
game his accuracy has been spot on I was
saying it's going to be a model game for
Nim onion I think it's going to be a
model game for how you play a rook B
ending we've been highlighting the peace
activity as well that F Pawn moving
forward white will have to give the Rook
for that pawn black will give his own
Rook for the B Pawn and then finally
that one extra Pawn the G Pawn will
decide the game and we see both pawns
moving forward this is just a matter of
a couple of moves and uh I think this is
busted for fedos he needs more than a
miracle to save this one he needs more
than 14 seconds as well time is not on
his side either he needs more pawns more
time I everything and there we go
resignation black was about to make a
new Queen napesi takes the lead
impressive game there impressive end
game
technique really good stuff by Yan she
starts with a win with the black beastes
in a best of two he's got white in the
next one needs only a draw to keep him
going in this event for fed that's big
danger he has to win and demand
meanwhile Ali Rea and Jose Martinez rob
it an active game but ended peacefully
there was some good chess in that game
but little can be done when both players
are playing precise chess so a draw
between Jose and alza a fair result and
yand Pals just outplayed his opponent
starting in the end game the worst Pawn
structure came back to haunt Vladimir
who he it was his own doing he played in
offbeat variation and unfortunately it
was him who got beaten so a great start
for Yan na pishi that's for sure it
really wasn't a great start for Yan
naishi in at the start of division one
he really struggled on day one but then
yesterday his comeback Victory against
Maxim V lra and his start today I think
this is the Yan that we love to see and
this is the Yan that can fight to become
the champion of the cherel Masters David
what are the chances of FV to come back
in this match and how do you think he
can make it happen it's GNA be tough for
FV losing with white we said it earlier
that is the worst possible start and
yanomi he's played these World
Championship matches he's got a
fantastic repertoire so many weapons
there he knows how to shut down games um
so I think for fed he'll need to launch
the first surprise he'll need to somehow
provoke Yan into some Muddy Waters where
it's not a simple path towards a draw
and the longer it goes on the one
downside we've seen from yand pishi
throughout his career some nerves do
creep in he's consistently been the
runner up of big big events and uh you
just need to kind of just hold him off
as long as possible I think a long game
will favor f
but Yan with white if he can lock it
down if he can simplify neutralize
Black's winning chances
early uphill struggle so Yan big big
favorite here but better say of the big
fish he's got to swim in a bigger pond
in this game and he's got to become a
shark for
sure Duffy needs to play some big moves
and get a big win in to take it into
Armageddon and we're off it's the
Sicilian that is at least a good news
not only for chess fans but also for
here that means that he will get some
play in it will probably be a
complicated middle game and just as I
say that Robert it's the Rosal Lio by
Yan Smart Choice from Yan napi because
instead of allowing this to venture into
those tactical Waters of a dragon where
there are exchange sacrifices and
checkmating ideas look at this position
thus far no Pawn tension he hasn't
actually pushed his Pawn to D4 and fed
says you are not going to do that I have
the central clamp so I would say both
sides should should be relatively happy
because as David said fed wants a long
game he proved yesterday that against
Magnus Carlson he can win in 100 plus
move battles but for Yan naishi he
doesn't have to worry about his King
being checkmated so I would say pluses
for both David I know you've have
experience in these quiet type positions
who do you think is happier about the
opening stage I think Yan objectively
will be thinking that white has an
advantage after all white has castled
the king White's pieces the knights the
light Square Bishop they're out in the
Center uh we always say that control the
Midfield control the center of the board
and you're H going to be in good stead
for the middle game he controls this
nice Square they are highlighting there
Robert big outpost on a light Square in
the middle of the board so kind of
taking the emotion out taking the
earlier result out I think Yan is happy
but uh fed cannot complain he's got all
of the pieces all 32 pieces still on
this board right now he's expanding
gaining space on the queen side he's got
some advantages of his own and more
importantly the game is alive it's
totally fresh I can guarantee neither
players studied this position before
despite yand pomnish speed um but for
black okay a big hit on that Queen he
needs to react he's played very quickly
up to this point but taking that Knight
in the center does look fraught with
danger and uh he might just have to go
for it he might have to kind of leave
the king in the center no he moves his
Queen instead um yeah I was trying to
talk purely about how the players are
feeling but now it's suddenly become
critical already some real calculation
to be done
W Tanya I'm wondering I was goingon to
ask you are we going to see G takes F6
here I'd love to I think the fans would
love to see that happen the commentators
would love it and the fact that
F the fact that he hasn't picked up that
night instantly we might be seeing that
appear on the board and that would mean
it would be an absolute wild position
black destroying the pawn structure on
the king side for the open G line the
more he thinks he's reaching out for his
Mouse right now will he play it safe
capture it with the queen or will we see
a g takes F eight goes for the queen
takes Knight oh I'm disappointed Robert
well I think it's the best move
objectively he probably wanted to play
GT like in in my heart I want to go all
out for the attack but it was
strategically very unsound so he is
choosing the correct continuation his
position is much worse as David
highlighted white has castled controls
the center has more pieces developed and
black has just been shuffling around
with the queen so this is a clear
Vantage now for yand pishi his latest
move A4 somehow it wasn't best and well
fed he's not responding with the most
accurate moves that's the nature of the
game when you have to win or you're
eliminated you you get into this state
of mind where the best move may get
close to a draw so let's play some move
that's speculative but at least forces
my opponent to calculate and I think
that both players are handling the match
situation
well I love that moment where you both
kind of in sync suggested G takes F6 um
I mean it wouldn't even be on my radar
but that's the type of move that
unexpected uh option often kind of going
against conventional wisdom you need to
just throw out there confuse your
opponent a bit I think feda feared if he
played an ugly move like that one
earlier that if he lost people would
have been you know mocking oh do you not
understand chess do you not understand
double pawns are bad so he's played what
should be correct but look at this the
evaluation bar now rising in White's
favor because he's profited he's used
his uh his kind of velopment advantage
to open up the center when you're ahead
uh when you control more Central squares
if things explode open up you're in
better position to uh kind of utilize
and look at this Knight jumping into F5
now that's the blue arrow highlighted by
the computer saying it's by far the best
move I'm also G to jump out and say it's
one of the most natural moves a knight
on F5 Black's King might not survive
question mark there white porn will
throw throw itself forward to F4 in the
near future as well I really fear look
at that black light Square Bishop
undeveloped the black Dart Square Bishop
is a target for the marauding pawns
Tanya um I know you're a great attacker
you must be salivating at the prospect
here of throwing those pieces forward
I'm flattered that you say that David
but I have to agree I mean just look at
White's position and yes visually it
looks amazing but even you can just see
exactly why it is Black's Pawn structure
worse than white compare each of white
species to Black species that Bishop on
D5 an absolute monster once that Knight
lands on 5 that's not a knight anymore
that's a stallion right there black will
have to find ways to neutralize that
maybe a move like Knight E7 might help
but it means more waste of time which
would give white the time to actually go
in with the idea of the pawn Avalanche
that you were earlier talking about F4
E5 coming in the bishop eventually
landing on to D4 I just feel like
White's playing everywhere doesn't rush
in with Knight F5 first putting pressure
onto C6 and it might not be the most
accurate move but I think it's a diff
it's also a practical approach and it
just keeps all the trumps in White's
position meanwhile black doesn't trade
on D4 not allowing Bishop D4 which would
have hit the queen on F6 falls back with
the Knight are we expecting the bishop
to retreat Robert or will he just keep
it there I would be tempted to retreat
make a move like Bishop back to B3 but
then I see that the black Bishop can
finally develop and poke at the White
Center some somehow things are getting a
little bit out of hand for Yan naami uh
the engine suggest that he's better here
that he hasn't spoiled his position but
it's getting complicated it was locked
up and now it's open and there's a
bishop staring at the white king this
queen on F6 is staring through the
knight at this loose Pawn on B2 and even
if objectively you can give up this Pawn
on B2 it gets scary when black has this
passer not too far away from it so I'm
looking at this position with a fresh
set of eyes David I think fos of he
feels locked in and like he suddenly has
chances because he's Wellhead in the
clock and the position is BEC a
mixed chess is all about momentum now he
jumps into F5 with his Knight but was it
a move too late now this uh I'm trying
to work it out I don't think it's quite
a pawn sacrifice but it is a big
committal decision um that's the thing
Yan his position was too nice in a way
with white he didn't want to do anything
he didn't want to spoil anything he just
moved his Rook to C1 what could be more
natural an open file but sometimes yeah
if you take your finger off the button
for a second or two the momentum
switches and um I think he's trying to
rec correct the course of this game by
throwing his Knight in maybe we jump in
here Robert and show the idea behind
this knight jump if black takes twice on
that square eliminates the White Knight
and then tries to snap up a
b okay well yeah this looks pretty good
for uh black but there are two problems
one Bishop takes F7 check it allows the
White Queen to hit a loose piece on D6
loose pieces drop off and that Bishop
will fall but there's also Bishop aiming
in the other direction because this Rook
is trapped thanks to both of these
bishops from the white side so it's
funny how I was first staring at the
king side then I saw the evaluation was
so high there must have been something
better and it's that this Rook is
trapped no safe squares available to it
and thus white wins material what a
position this is and I do not believe
that fedos is going to fall for this
because as we mentioned even Bishop
takes F7 check instead looks very good
to my eyes but after the trade of
knights on F5 if we get this position
it's up to Vladimir to find some useful
looking move Bishop A7 that will trap
The Rook if you're not careful that
actually is a threat on the board and so
Vladimir now he has his work cut out for
him after the swap of
knights big moment and he solves the
problem of that threat by offering a
trade of light Square Bishops and uh
here we go those Bishops have left the
board it does look like white has an
advantage but let's uh zoom out of this
one temporarily we also have another
game going in the losers quarterfinals
and uh here we see actually almost
symetry in terms of the evaluation bars
the first thing I looked over at it
looks like fera has an advantage but
it's a different type of advantage to
npom Nishi uh the board we see on the
right there fuja against Martinez very
very blocked white has more space hence
the advantage but uh still a lot to play
for um what do you make of this Tanya
the body language the clock times the
kind of first glance at the position I
think it's really interesting that
White's the one with double pawns but in
this particular case the double pawns
actually give White
an edge a chance because it opens up the
aile and creates a target for white on
that A5 Pawn White's got these long-term
ideas are perhaps even doubling up on
the a file but at least for now it's
making sure that Black's Rook on eight
is tied down and I think whenever black
pushes that a pawn to A4 white can
actually just keep the double pawns as
they are you can just think about moving
your B Pawn to B4 taking away that C5
Square tying down that B5 pawn and one
of White's black pieces will have to
defend that pawn for a really long time
you pointed out the space and Robert uh
David added to that the attack on the a
file I I think that explains why White's
the one who's pushing in this
position I like everything he says yeah
feels like there's a big hole Robert
sorry I'm zoned in on the C6 Square just
we need to highlight that one it looks
like a dream Outpost for any of wh
pieces but the problem is a knight can't
get there very easily because the pawns
cover the entry points but a rook can
but ala fua says Tanya your idea it's
pretty good let me go ahead and double
The Rook so I actually think that black
may have to play this move A4 even if
you don't want to because you end up
freezing your own Pawn structure it's
you're going to lose the a pawn
otherwise so A4 to my eyes looks
reasonable another move is Rook C8
there's an open file you should put your
Rook on it and the big question that I
have David is that if this a pawn is in
fact lost and I actually don't see an
easy way to keep it defended because
even after A4 Rook A1 comes to mind does
black have drawing chances chances to
equalize by playing arounded playing for
activity want to say yes for Jose
Martinez's sake but I think dropping a
pawn here unless something really
magical happens unless he somehow gets
the black Bishop into the game the Black
Knight on D7 into the game it's going to
be a real struggle um to seek
compensation you always need active
pieces and U maybe that black Bishop
comes in now that's one way to defend
that a
um Tak a bit of a journey a bit of a
path around it takes three moves
essentially to reactivate itself but in
a block position maybe you do have that
luxury it definitely feels like his
back's against the wall and Martinez
he's great at kind of finding resources
when it looks like things are going
against him but uh yeah I do fear just
with the Simplicity of White's moves the
Simplicity of White's plans that Tanya
pointed out that uh even if he finds
some compostition it's going to take him
a bunch of time on the clock and already
we see him a minute down maybe soon upon
down yeah I would take FIA here all day
long the more I look at this position
the more I see the strength in these
double pawns uh right now he doesn't go
for the idea of Bishop B7 bishop d8 and
I think that's a really great defensive
resource you spotted David he's going
for the activity and that is classic
Jose Martinez he doesn't believe in
passive defense he's always trying for a
way where he can keep his pieces active
even if it comes at the cost of material
now the problem here is that even if
black was to step up firstly you can't
go Queen to C7 because that Queen needs
to stay connected to the B5 Pawn as well
actually don't see a way for the pawn to
stay alive on A5 uh which means you're
going to go down a pawn and now I'm just
wondering where is this activity that
Jose is looking for he goes A4 and white
just grab this take it with your Pawn
take it with the rook and to me it just
looks like an extra Pawn Robert it is an
extra Pawn but at least the queen on B8
will stare down in open Line The Rook on
C8 is in a fully open file so this is
what Jose is relying on whether it's
going to pan out for him is a different
question but at least he is giving
himself a clearer plan because the path
in front of his pieces has now opened up
so this Pawn can and is captured this
black queen can slide up to B3 there's
Rook C2 potentially to follow in fact I
didn't even draw the blue arrow that was
the engine telling us that you he had to
play Queen B3 it's given an exclamation
point it also was the point of his Pawn
sacrifice in this manner so David I
think that black we can see clear
counterplay but is it enough would you
feel comfortable at all with the black
pieces I'd never feel comfortable
playing against ala fuja especially with
black he's a beast when he has white
he's beaten me in some of the biggest
games in my career when he has the white
pieces but uh yeah I think actually Jose
he's done the best of a bad job uh of a
bad position at least he's kind of
chosen the Lesser evil being a porn down
um I think he's just uh playing kind of
hustling here a bit but he's doing the
right thing you have to play for that
activity you cannot just suffer
passively and let your opponent slow
slowly at will at their own discretion
outplay you so yeah he's done a good job
at least the clock situation which I was
a bit worried about uh it's kind of
turned in his favor suddenly due to this
active play and against fua you have to
fight fire with fire or firea with firea
and yeah I think he's uh doing a good
job here but talking of being a porn
down maybe we zoom out to the other game
just for a quick update while FIA takes
a longer think um because it's also a PN
down situation for fev and that is bad
news not just in terms of the fact that
npom Nishi is objectively better but
white only needs a draw and Nishi here
with an a extra pawn it should be in the
bank
Tanya yeah I mean this end game just
looks like again it's all white play
Black is trying to Target the F5 Pawn
fed trying to attack both the A5 and the
F5 Pawn but F6 is weak uh for Yan he can
actually go ahead and pick up one more
pawn and the thing is FV needs a win in
this position a draw is just not enough
even if he manages to survive upon down
he is out of the cheser bble Masters
where is he going to create his winning
chances here Robert where do you see how
do you see that even being a possibility
a hope here you have to rely on your dwn
I guess I know the answer to the
question is realistically Jan is not
going to lose this game but if it's
going to come from anywhere for fedos he
does have a pass Pawn that can't easily
march on the board his Rook on B5 hits
the F5 Pawn hits that A5 Pawn as you men
so white does have a few things to
figure out but I'm looking at this and
I'm wondering why can't white just
continue snacking on pawns and trading
off more pieces because there aren't so
many pawns remaining in this position I
don't see winning chances for black I'm
trying to come up with something but I
even this the advantage is given away
but black needs to win not
draw so tough here fed of 3 minutes on
the clock and uh as we were saying it's
just a tough tough position he does go
passive with the black Bishop to defend
but look at this really classy end game
play really beautiful move there I saw
your reaction Robert just locking
Black's pawns on dark squares that is a
fixed Target now it's not running away
anytime soon that black pawn the white
Bishop can slide at will back to pick it
off and then White's hbn becomes a real
monster maybe a potential future Queen
there exclamation mark for good reason
Robert that's a lovely move yeah you are
just cementing that pawn in place fix it
on the color that your Bishop is on so
the black Bishop is a passive piece is
defending these loose Pawns in the
position sorry that's the third loose
pawn and white fixes that pawn on H6
lovely decision I'm not really worried
at all for yand pishi it does seem like
he's just a few moves away from winning
so why don't we maybe head back to our
other game where there is a little bit
more tension and drama because it's half
to half they drew their first game and
in game two between aliv zaa and Jose
Martinez look at the position now and
Jose he's trying to occupy the B file go
after White's extra Pawn it's not like
white has the clearest plan in the world
it is black to move but David why can't
you just grab this Pawn on B2 now I
don't see any reason not to a porn is a
porn as you mentioned earlier in another
game I hate being pawns down for no
reason so why not restore the balance um
that's one load off the mind I guess
white will either trade off or maybe
even go active with the white Queen uh
Queen to C7 but then it becomes a bit
more random I don't see any exact
specific threats for white um it looks
nice and pretty kind of lined up on the
seventh rank with the White Queen and
Rook
but next where do you go next um I don't
reason to pause I guess Jose doesn't
need to rush that pawn might be
available next move um really kind of
tense tense position but evaluation bar
here Tanya I feel it's
deceptive I'm looking at that extra Pawn
to neutralize that you have to pick it
up I really like the idea of keeping the
queens and not shading it off Queen to
C7 the other move that comes to mind is
even Queen to C6 it can be really scary
handling that he is touching the two and
a half minute Mark both players are
under three minutes uh once the queen
lands on the sixth of the seventh rank
there are big threats on the board Queen
C6 would threaten Rook takes Knight on
D7 and he does go to capture the B2 pawn
and we see this first question how do
you parry this big threat I don't
believe you can really move that Knight
anywhere because if you do that then
there are ideas against the F7 Pawn if
you were to go Knight to C5 or Knight to
B6 then you move Queen C7 really comes
with a big double attack on that F7 pawn
and also the Rook but look at this
passive defense it's given a miss that
means the knight jump probably was
better but as you said t very difficult
to move the Knight when the F7 Pawn was
in The Rook sights but David to your
point from earlier I don't see how white
crashes through you can make all sorts
of little improving moves King H2 is a
nice one making sure there's no check on
the first rank over here but let's say
black gets passive Queen to B8 I'm G to
try to play Rook C8 to kick your queen
out of there or try to trade Queens so
David where are the inroads from oi
raz's perspective he's got more space
he's got more control but you need to
actually Target and take something at
some point it's not going to be easy uh
I still think from a human point of view
both players probably assume wh's
slightly better but they won't assume
it's a b advantage and um Robert you
mentioned the weaknesses there aren't
many actually in Black's Camp uh it must
just be the D6 pawn and that is a
backward pawn and it's only defended by
Black's passive Bishop someday
eventually it might take time White's
Knight is going to come back via D2 over
to C4 uh just to sit and pressure that
pawn for good first there's a hit on the
White Queen so the White Queen needs to
move uh where do you Retreat her I don't
know if you can step forward um Queen to
C7 now might just run into a hit with
the move moves like Rook to
D7 maybe you step back Queen to A4 Queen
to C4 I think you just need to maneuver
improve I Want To Praise Fu's King to H2
move though that shows he's played a
bunch of Blitz and bullet in his life
you never want to allow a check when
your clock is ticking down but uh yeah
it's going to be a long long grind it's
going to take a while to maneuver and
only then start to set up the tactics
for white David alza doesn't step back
what are the chances of him going Queen
to a the move looks crazy and maybe it's
too much cuz you're lining your queen
against The Rook but I don't see an
immediate big knight jump Queen a is
that a possibility wow I was not looking
in that direction at all David I I know
you you're like wait that's a legal
Square to go to yeah that's that's a
really cool move I think black may be
forced to bring the Rook up well now
definitely Rook D7 but even after queen8
bringing the Rook to the seventh rank
this queen on B2 it's really doing
excellent work covering so many squares
and pieces but now that the Rooks are
getting traded off and okay this is
Black's only move according to the
engines but it also is very natural and
replacing the Rook with the Knight
afterwards once again I keep asking this
question mainly to myself but also out
loud how is white going to make progress
from there the D6 Pawn is not easy to
get to especially because E4 and F2 and
White's Camp need to be
defended we saw a shake of the head as
well from Jose Martinez before he traded
off those Rooks but if I were him I
would be breathing a sigh of relief uh
he essentially traded of his own bad
Rook for White's very strong Rook uh it
must just be based on a very direct
attempt attempt at Victory here fora
he's going in for the kill with the
white knight but the White Knight is not
jumping any further there is a check you
can check but the black king just moves
and look at this the blue arrow the
computer says White's best move is to
admit defeat and go back just admit that
your last move was mistaken and uh there
simply a hit on your E4 Pawn so he might
have to find this Robert is it just me
or is momentum changing things are
turning on bord and clock momentum is
changing so it is in The Other Board I'm
going have to quickly bring up this one
I cannot believe what I'm seeing over
here feder is winning because Checkmate
in one is threatened white stole the H
Pawn that's the good news but black has
this dewn that is quicker and checkm and
one is threatened I'm in just utter
disbelief how in the world did this go
wrong for y pami he can't believe it
fedos say went Tanya
what whoa
Yi resigns FV wins the game comes back
in the match takes it into Armageddon a
game that we had written off as one that
Yan napi can never lose Rook to G3 chat
would have been a massive one forcing
King to H4 and how do you fight it
because you're not only fighting this
check you're fighting the D Pawn as well
D3 D2 D1 is just queening you can't do
anything about it and he just gives up
and yeah with a shake of his head he
can't believe it either
David and I just went back to check uh
two moves ago Yan was still winning it
was self-inflicted he pushed his own
Pawn to F4 he blocked in his own Bishop
he pretty much trapped his own white
king yeah we're showing this now Robert
as we see Yan kind of smiling and kind
of laughing at what he did Pawn to F4
question mark he's trapped his own King
walked into a mating n and after the
next move Rook to E3 brilliant fine from
FV he didn't realize until it was too
late napesi taking that pawn on H6 and
after Bishop to E1 as Robert pointed out
Rook G3 is a killer threat the pawn is
rolling game over it went from winning
to losing in two moves chess is brutal
rapid chess is so
unforgiving what a finish to that game
and I think when you're much better for
most of the game your opponent just kind
of flailing and uh doing random things
you just assume that nothing's going to
work but fedos have never stopped
calculating he's kind of like the
Undertaker know he's coming back from
the dead against Magnus Carlson and now
against yand pomi and as we dive back
into this game between fuja and Jose
Martinez well the same problems persist
for black there's this D6 Pawn that's
targeted a number of times but I just
don't think white has enough Firepower
to keep attacking it Tanya look at the
clock Jose down now under 13
seconds W he's touching that 10c Mark he
makes the move he can only Shuffle
around with the King and stay passive
keep those pawns defended there isn't
much activity to fight for but he's
taking control of White's King squar not
allowing White's King an entry point
trying to trade off as many pawns as
possible and both players playing on
seconds right now it's still where is
the winning chance is white going to
March all the way from the queen side
over with his King
David possibly I think the simple plan
now is there is a threat Knight to B5
he's defended his Central points with
the white king and the other three of
his army are going to go for that
backward Pawn the black D6 Pawn but hose
is fighting so tenaciously he's trying
to use his own Knight to go for the
white king some checks some hits on the
white pawns but look at this all of
White's pieces this is the picture of
teamwork three of them ganging up on one
Soul weakness missed opportunity
apparently according to the computer but
looks very logical to me and again the
white king defending the rest of the
pieces attacking and a P sacrifice
desperation from jfam here he's going to
get two white pawns but White's going to
be left with one key remaining porn this
one's over Robert yes this was a nice
retreating move as well from fuja he
secured extra material now he stopped
his knight from coming to F4 it goes
there anyway but this is a winning end
game at this stage for white D5 is gone
you can't actually defend the pawn H4
comes next and as long as you keep your
last Pawn do not allow this to get two
knights and a king versus a bear King
because that is the draw in fact fuja
wins by resignation because he knows
that Jose's not gonna get that H3 Pawn
fua he survives Jose Martinez his time
in the ches Masters is done but what a
run he had but it does come to an end
Jose Martinez is eliminated from the
chessable Masters Ali Resa fuja
continues his run I've got to say that
last position and that game too he did
it convincingly and these are our score
lines it's not over in the losers
quarterfinals because we've got a big
Armageddon coming up as Vladimir FV the
score a win in the second game a
miraculous win a miraculous save and to
me Robert David it is so reminiscent of
what happened in the F of Maxim B lra
match up Maxim was completely winning in
that armagon against F but just the last
minute slip just sort of becoming a
little casual at the very end and it
costus him a big win in that matchup uh
this one goes into Armageddon what are
we expecting has the momentum shifted
psychologically as well I think it
definitely has I mean for Vladimir FV he
earned his way through but David take us
through how this went so wrong for Yan I
just wanted to go through a slow action
replay of what happened Yan Naomi on the
brink of winning his match pretty much
played a perfect game up to here it
looks like white is winning it's all due
to the weakness of this Pawn the
weakness of the F6 Pawn as well but fed
sa this is a tip for everyone at home
keep fighting keep looking for tricks
for resources first this bishop is
offside doing nothing he brought it into
the game via D2 to protect this pawn and
this provoked the mistake here Yan with
a calmer mind a cooler mind he would
have simply gone for the other weakness
the F6 Pawn maybe even he could have
just pinned this bishop with a big
Advantage a winning position but always
look out for your king even deep into
the end game Pawn to F4 as Robert
highlighted earlier was the mistake not
just a mistake but a pair of mistakes
after Rook to E3 a big big threat here
and unfortunately after Bishop takes
Pawn Yan still oblivious now the threat
landed on the board and uh just to show
what could have happened if for example
White had moved the bishop again
clearing the path for this Pawn this
would have been a nasty check the white
king now forced to move and a beautiful
discovered check hitting the white king
winning the white Rook on the next turn
so always watch out for your king Never
Take Your Eye Off the ball and don't
forget the opponent Yan unfortunately
there just uh yeah relaxing one move too
early and now has to pay that price with
an
Armageddon it's a reset he needs to do
it all over again against Vladimir FV in
the rapid match two big wins by the
black pastes in the bids how low are the
players going to go to try and get black
we will be back with the big Armageddon
and the bits do not go
anywhere
[Music]
but the goal is get you to a comfortable
spot in those first 10 opening moves and
just have you hit in that
gas That's all folks thanks so much for
checking out my E4 course here on
chessable I do hope you
[Music]
[Applause]
enjoy I got introduced to chess because
uh my family
is obviously both my mom and dad's side
is from uh former Soviet Union uh and
it's kind of part of the culture there
so I was playing with my grandfather
when I was about five and I I I think
What attracted me when I was younger is
I just got the game I got the game
probably on the level how most modern
day Grand Masters got the game I could
see something once and I could just go
demolish adults kids uh and and for most
talented players that's how it is for a
long time they just obsessed over the
game
I hate to compare it to Art but in many
ways it is I find it fascinating every
day I can teach myself something played
it for 20 years and there's still so
much I don't know I can play Blitz Games
and I can make Masterpiece or chaos with
white with black what a time to be alive
you know because I still have insecure
chess teacher Syndrome from 2019 when I
was just going to private lessons and
nobody knew who I was and I still
remember those days and like like I very
easily just think about them and I I'm
not I'm completely the same guy I just
happen to do it on camera now
now last World Championship I was
looking at five streams at the same time
like getting all the information trying
to understand the position more uh like
I keeping in mind what I'm going to say
in the recap a couple hours later who
who said what that's the stuff that that
I really get excited by just knowing
that it was it was a good recording it
was funny it was I presented everything
I want to present uh that stuff I guess
is like a cycle that that gets me more
energy I really enjoy making a high
quality piece of content it it is very
natur for me uh to do the presenting
like I'm not fake at all I think that's
one of the reasons I can I can stream
and stay but like sometimes even I'm
exhausted and after I record a video I
have more energy which doesn't make
[Music]
sense I feel good about the current
career I I don't spend a huge amount of
time being uh introspective about the
current career I I'm just working as
hard as
possible with me it's just me me in the
camera which which is even I don't know
I would even argue it's more weird that
it's just me in a room from 2020 until
now I'm still just some dude who likes
to talk about Chess and I just so happen
to do it in a uh in an exciting way for
a lot of people and obviously okay my
confidence has grown in presenting and
knowing that what I put out will get
watched which is you don't have that
guarantee when you start it's very nice
and it's not something I I take uh
lightly but at the end of the day if you
really break it down and just a dude who
talks but
[Music]
chest ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to another
video I've taken an approach in this
course where I will happily enter the
main lines of certain openings for the
first 5 or 10 movs before deviating into
something that's aggressive
interesting
[Music]
take
EX
[Music]
oh
and we are going to have the Armageddon
between these two friends well there's
no friendship going into the next one as
it will be all about that clock and who
gets the winning bid and we've got the
bids with
us look at that it is Vladimir FV who
wins the bit 7 minutes 35 seconds
yamashi bidding 8 minutes he didn't go
that low what do you make of this big
Robert Vladimir P starts with the black
pieces well yand pishi has shown a
tendency to prefer the white pieces in
armag again yesterday against Maxim Vash
lra he also had white but while he won
the game it wasn't pretty he was in fact
losing before Maxine brought his King in
too far so I don't know if I love the
bid I think fedos is going to be happy
taking
black H yesterday uh he had an
experience against Magnus Carson when he
had the white pieces a lot of pressure
there now things have changed up we see
the caroan defense black is temporarily
sacrificed to porn but will win that
back on this turn and fed this is one of
his favorite openings with white with
black one of his highest score openings
now however a hit against a weak spot on
G7 don't bring your queen up too early
folks unless you're a Grandmaster and
you know when to get away with it
White's Queen doing
uh some really annoying work there and
now after creating weakness it's time to
get castled um Robert I've got to say
time Advantage having an extra couple of
minutes in what is likely to be a
complicated middle game now it surely
will stand the punishing in good stad
yeah there's something about this
opening that I don't like even if you
give me a ton of time from the black
side look at all these holes in the dark
squares and this bishop on C5 well if it
gets back to G7 maybe I feel a little
bit better but still not so fantastic so
I that wasn't me I thought I misclicked
he actually just brought his Bishop back
to fa that is one of the wildest
predictions I've had that's insane it
reminds me of your prediction of Bishop
to see7 I mean how did that even happen
I still think about it when it was a one
move lunder and I think you dropped it
and Magnus dropped it and right now
Bishop to F another bishop move Robert
the prophet strikes again the bishop
does land on G7 but I think you can't
explain in this one the dark Square
weakness that you were pointing out for
Black's King to be safe on the king side
it's so critical for black to have that
fan
Bishop I think we should rename you
Robert fed Robert Sayes because uh yeah
it's just you and you and Vladimir here
you're so in sync and uh the downside I
guess behind this bishop maneuver is it
costs a lot of time look how many white
pieces are out there pouring forward
already White Queen all the minor pieces
the white rook and in the center1 yes
the pawn structure is locked blocked for
now but if things open up white is by
far the more ready to pounce uh so fed
of living life on the edge uh Robert
he's played your maneuver he's now
attacking the white E5 Pawn do you see
him unraveling untangling from this
position I think he's doing a good job
thus far because he's forcing Yan to
slow down and now we see that the
difference in clock is 2 minutes so I
think from that perspective fed must be
happy but he hasn't developed any of his
pieces if I'm yand pomi I don't want to
give up this Central Pawn maybe there
are some tactics available to White that
allow you to give up E5 because the
black king remains in the center but I
probably would just drop my Bishop back
to F4 I know I put my Bishop on G5 a
turn too but I want to keep this Pawn on
E5 and he does it in a different way
with Queen to G3 I like that as well so
atata I would say from a strategic Point
White's doing well but I think fedos
have he maybe in this comfort zone of
this Wy type of opening where he feels
at home he's going to feel more at home
once that knight from G8 can come out
and the only parts that I see is from E7
he does hit the bishop right now so
forcing Yan to take a decision you've
got to fall back with that bishop and
then I'm expecting fedf to continue with
his development Knight to E7 maybe
someday it will land on F5 but you've
got to be careful you've got to watch
out before you make that move go Knight
E7 get your king to safety put that
Bishop on D7 start advancing the B Pawn
and it does look like things have
started uh looking slightly more
playable for black more space for white
though that said David Bishop falls back
to F4 do you think that Yan should be
happier out of the opening outcome right
now Yan would not complain if you
offered him this position with an extra
minute on his clock beforehand but uh
there is a bit of pressure now long-term
black has a lot of potential black is
rock solid black has no real weaknesses
if pieces start to disappear if Knights
Bishops Queens get traded off actually
if anyone's better it's going to be
black due to having two Central pawns
white only having one in the center
white E5 porn looks very strong now but
could become a weakness uh so time is
very much of the essence in Armageddon
as always but also on the board PA A3
might look like a timid move but watch
out if black ever has the courage to
Castle quinide White will oh he's
setting it up now with Bishop D7 white
will throw pawns forward Pawn to B4 Pawn
to B5 and uh explode that flank so
really really Cy stuff right now I think
Yan needs to act quickly Pawn to H4 he's
kind of bluffing now he's playing on
both sides of the board with pawns he's
asking whether the black king is gonna
go and no this isn't a mous step either
Robert K to f8 this is a standard plan
when your kingside is under attack that
what leaves your Rook as a defensive
piece and white can't team up on it but
I love the move from Yan neomi Knight D1
Knight E3 Knight G4 and the H6 pawn and
the F6 Square are accessible from the
Knight so this Knight is doing a bit of
dancing it's going on a a real adventure
and black says I'm not even going to
think about your night getting there
Tanya I have to say I like this change
in Pawn structure for black because now
the position isn't as one-sided and I
think this last move really explains
that King's s step it wasn't a mous slip
it was a move with the plan the king
from fa defended that Bishop in G7 so
allowing fedf to go Knight to F5
tradeoff having double pawns but opening
up the G line for counter play so again
and a double-edged game but let's remind
everyone that fedos needs only a draw
it's so important for him to keep the
clock under control and to not get the
position super messy because for Yan he
has to go all out he's the one who's in
a must-win game right now so this kind
of complication this kind of a double
situation does it seem to favor Yan more
than
fev especially after these last couple
of moves Yan suddenly he's played two or
three quick instant replies and look at
the white porn he's gained all the space
on the center on the queen side yes this
last move given a question mark But
White's Knight has the most beautiful
perch you'll ever see an outpost on D4
um so Yan I think he's got enough pieces
enough control here to guarantee a long
game and with two extra minutes on the
clock in Armageddon no increment that
could be decisive I would love to play
two moves in a row if I could with white
I was going to say Knight D4 and pawn to
H5 just to stop any Knight G6 ideas and
um yeah it just feels like Yan he's in
his element right now it's not a winning
Advantage it's not even maybe a
significant Advantage but um f to say 4
minutes on the clock it's not going to
be easy at all Robert do you think uh
wow King to G8 first of all with a blue
arrow there do you think that's natural
I was going to say do you think fed is
comfortable with this position oh
clearly King to G8 wasn't that natural
because he brings his Rook to G8 and how
could you blame him bringing his Rook to
an open line where the enemy Queen is
but this bishop on G7 can't move so
tactically speaking this isn't going to
work out for black you don't want to
drop this H6 Pawn so this position is
difficult for both sides the bishop on
A4 that is a nasty piece because you
can't bring a rook to D1 you can't march
your pawns forward on B4 and C5 so I
think both sides have things to be happy
about I see the engine evaluation off
the side I don't care about that I both
players are recognizing that it's not
easy to break through so Tanya and look
at white getting the queen out the way
what is the actual plan for either side
frankly we're going to wait and watch
that being played out I think there are
two ideas black can perhaps aim at
trying to trade off that very strong
Knight on D4 eventually come with his
own Knight to C6 trying to exchange as
many pieces as possible but that said
the current position with the number of
pieces on the board with both players
well fedy have under five minutes and
Yan pami touching the five minute Mark
and what we have in front of us I think
we're in for a wild time scramble in
this one and it is going to come into
who's faster on the mouse who's got that
extra seconds on the clock I'm expecting
some peace trades to happen and he does
it Knight C6 on the board Robert a good
decision by fed it is a good decision
and he needs to control those light
squares and when it's a closed position
Knights are often Superior to Bishop so
that's why there's one Knight on D4
perhaps a second Knight can replace it
because the Knight appears over the
block position whereas Bishops if there
was a bishop on D4 instead it would
stare into its own Pawn so that's why
these Knights are looking so promising
and that is why T recommended the trade
of these so David if these kns I maybe
not even say if when these Knights come
off the board do you see how to further
make progress because it looks like a
completely blockaded
position it's tough It's Not Easy and um
therefore kind of with the lack of
obvious plans I'm inclined to agree with
tan and say it's going to be a time
scramble pretty much guaranteed and at
some point you just need to make moves
even if you're not kind of progressing
advancing your position not kind of
making inroads into uh kind of Black's
camp for example if you're yand pishi
King H2 a great move for example you
just tease your opponent bring that Rook
to G1 pretend you're going to play G4
maybe you do play Pawn to G4 uh either
way you've got extra time on the clock
and there we go he's now attacking and
uh it's far easier to attack as we all
know than it is to defend with that
clock ticking down so under four minutes
now fed big decision does he have to
take on G4 allow the White Knight closer
to that black king the black king is
almost actually in a mating net as it is
uh no real Escape squares fedf presses
the chaos button instead Pawn to F6
Robert clock board it's all just
exploded in this last couple of moves it
certainly has and if G takes F5 is the
only move to leave white with the
advantage this position is much trickier
than the evaluation bar would let us
believe now Yan this was a natural move
from if this Pawn takes on E5 yes it
looks like a fork as G takes F received
an exclamation point but there's a queen
on F3 there is a king on f8 you don't
want to see all the pieces get out the
way so there will be tactics that allow
white not just to save the material but
win some material so in this position I
think if you're Vladimir you just slide
your queen on over to F7 it's going to
be a bad position but at least the white
king doesn't feel that safe Tanya we
could see the makings of a lad checkmate
with a rook on the G file and if this
queen somehow some way can get to a
square like
H4 whoa and I'm just looking at the
decision that fos have has just taken
and I was wondering is this even
possible because I thought that W could
actually push the E Pawn and create play
against the double pawns but he goes for
a more direct idea doesn't sacrifice the
pawn opens up the bishop but the
downside of doing it this way Robert to
me is that black gets play as well
grabbing on F6 now that fed's Bishop is
active I think that gives black some
hope in this position I was expecting E6
at that moment yeah that would have been
a nice move instead of capturing and
David now that you know we're here we
can revisit uh that moment a little bit
later this Knight on E3 is pinned and
this white King on H2 if this black king
slinks to the corner whose King do you
think is actually
safer I would love to be fed suddenly
out of the blue not just because
objectively maybe he's got more chances
now but um it's just pure lack of
control it's an IR rational position
npom she has no idea what's going on we
kind of have to calculate here just to
try and figure out who's better but uh
as you say if the black queen activates
if the black Rook on E8 gets one more
move comes down to
E4 I really fear for the white king the
black king at least Black's moves are
easy that's all you want in the time
scramble Knight takes Pawn now check
forcing the black king into the corner
and yeah that whiteing look at the air
around it look at all the possible
checkmating patterns there's so many of
them um I agree Robert the evaluation
bar still favors white but this has been
turning and uh if momentum continues as
it is I think feder have he's got great
chances now um suddenly the narrow path
that white has to tread it's only
getting narrower and narrower every
single move what do you even play here
with white your Rook is hanging in the
center Nishi I wouldn't be surprised if
he tanks now and uh kind of slips up
it's so easy to go wrong wow this
position has turned completely ananya
we've talked about fedro yesterday
against Magnus Carlson it looked like he
was on his way down to the losers
bracket and he won a game on time then
in Armageddon he had the upper hand he
couldn't find the Tactical sequence
Magnus was able to escape with the match
Victory and here it looked like
everything was going wrong for Vladimir
and now his King has scurried on over to
the corner Vladimir is actually the one
ahead on time let's not forget we're not
getting these two seconds of increment
with every turn Jan is in serious time
trouble now this is Armageddon Yan has
to win this game he's got the white
pieces he's got no increment he's Below
on the clock it's his Rooks that are
hanging right now Yan does look calm but
I don't think he's got to he's going to
be that calm on the inside the first big
question is what is his next move I
would think that he would just trade on
E8 immediately right my Rook on D4 is
hanging my Rook on E1 is hanging what is
he thinking about right now what are the
other moves is Rook E4 rookie for is not
even possible what am I saying I mean
what do you even play here there no easy
moves that's the problem but he's got to
just choose something for better or
worse he's got to trade Rooks as you say
Tanya maybe leave that white Rook on D4
and wow he was calculating this but look
at the evaluation bar we said it so easy
to go wrong double question mark move
I'm wondering what he has in store if
the black Dart Square Bishop just takes
that white Rook a free piece in the
center he's got to go for checkmate now
against the black king but maybe there
isn't one he's now down a minute on the
clock I'm thinking again Robert he's
miscalculated he's me missed something
here and look at this the blue arrow it
strikes Queen takes F7 a queen sacrifice
because the Rook on E1 is loose at the
end and black will have two Rooks and a
bishop and an attack against the white
king so this is going to be too much
material in Black's favor f look at him
he is locked in and he senses the moment
for yand pomi it's a bad sign when you
give away a rook and then you still
think afterwards his time in the ches
Masters could come to an end in the next
few moves but I think Robert it's
critical for FV to play this move
because if you were to move up with your
king which he does can't why give a
check on D3 trade on E8 and pick up the
bishop on
D4 oh did you did you see Nomi lean back
with surprise that he look he feels that
he's got a second life now and he has he
has to go for that variation that you
mentioned Tanya it's strictly forced but
more importantly he needs to move one
minute left it's still chaotic we're
miles away from a decision on this game
from the climax he needs to move one
minute it's bullet chess now he's living
life on the edge it's going to be about
flagging David this is going to be about
flagging and it's game on right now he
goes for this gives a
check rookie for the blue arrows here
it's the only move it makes sense to
keep the bishop defended if you think
you're going to attack a knight Queen G6
would be checkm he walked into he walked
into a meeting
net my gosh now he's only got one legal
move he has to block and White's just
motoring forward White's going to
Checkmate or win the black queen the
black Bishop is overworked overloaded
he's got a flag Nomi now only chance
he's down a queen for rook and Bishop
he's lost oh that was a tragic turnar
around but I will say there are still
chances for black thanks to this Pawn on
D4 it's not going to be you know an easy
win for white whose own King is in
trouble Tanya we've seen crazier things
happen than a black win in this
game I completely agree with you and for
yanami he's got to wrap it up with just
40 seconds no increment the two Bishops
Super Active F3 Pawn always Under Fire
look at that evalar already a mistake by
Yan can black actually just capture on
F3
now maybe he can he's considering it he
can win back the White Queen immediately
but first he grabs another pawn and
white gives a check another check but
all of the white pawns are dropping a
draw is good enough for black to
progress here and you cannot deliver
checkmate with a queen alone so he's
using his Bishop but he's dropping all
his pawns here Robert
yeah yeah you can just keep trading
pieces and in fact I think black will
have a fortress at the end you put your
Rook on the seventh rank or actually why
not this configuration these pieces are
Untouchable here everything protects
something else and if this Rook gets to
D7 I mean how do you expect to win this
game with a rook behind the pass P what
a defense from
fedos
unbelievable oh he
M win King H6 Queen to E8 is the
Checkmate y she is one move away from
winning this there's no way to fight it
Rook E7 runs into Queen F6 and you pick
up the
Rook over so quickly so
suddenly just going to win the black
Rook now and nothing to be done it's all
about flagging 23 seconds look at the
speed they're going to show they're
going to display but white has an extra
Queen surely this is over now will we
see another comeback no more pre moves
npom Nishi he's got this in the bank
he's win thing about yanam she's also a
great bullet player and this one I mean
now it's two Queens on the board it's
done oh my gosh and Vladimir fedos have
so close yet so far and yishi throwing
his hands in the air unbelievable
Armageddon oh my
god wow I don't have the words I really
don't have the words for what we just
saw and you know fedos his lights were
flickering but they've completely dimmed
his tournament is done with in the Chess
Masters he's been a wrecking ball of
sorts he took down Aliva fua he gave
Magnus every bit of a fight and against
yand pishi just when he had everything
under control He Slipped the players I
believe they're talking to one another
they know each other well fedos said say
of me even though he's bowed out of the
competition he has proven that he is a
force and we have seen him so many times
in the last season win division 2 The
Big Fish I no doubt will be back with
some big games in the Champions Chester
what an armag get and we saw the players
discuss the moves out in the end because
it was that crazy David I think this was
one of the most exciting ends to a match
that we've seen one of the most
fascinating Armageddon take us through
the big
moments this was incredible so many
highlights from that Armageddon alone
but I just wanted to show the final
mistake where it all slipped away from
fed sa's grasp and it was here we were
just praising him for being the comeback
King for defending a really difficult
position and saving it with black a draw
being enough with Armageddon to progress
but one slip was all it took here the
black porn is very strong but you can
just leave it abandon it if you keep
your formation for example like this
King to G7 and uh just kind of keep your
Rook just maintain it on the the f file
there's no way forward for white The
Rook the bishop the king they'll protect
each other curl up into a ball this is
the definition of a fortress instead
such bad luck for fed he played Rook to
D7 in this position he broke the
formation and allowed the white king
forward this was a really accurate check
the only winning move from yand pomi and
as we know kings in the corner are
susceptible to mating patterns King to
H6 exclamation mark from npom nesi
spotting his only opportunity because
there are no checks black cannot defend
this is a deadly Checkmate threat on the
back rank Queen to F6 is also a threat
and at what happened in the game Rook to
C7 defending the square allowed a check
another check and because the Rooks
undefended it was simply game over
things turn so quickly in Armageddon
chess it was a time scramble ultimately
neishi was the one to
Triumph unbelievable moral of the story
keep your pawns closed but keep your
Rooks even closer I mean what was that
what a turn around Yana pish she seconds
away from being eliminated and then just
makes a big comeback but you make your
own luck on the chessboard you make your
own resources and he kept going and
that's what we saw it's not over till
it's over and today it's not over
because we've got a big big Winners
final coming up as well Robert I mean so
many highlights as well from uh from our
losers
bracket besides the armagan what else
comes to your mind i' I've forgotten
everything that else that happened
before this yeah let's be honest the Ala
win over Jose Martinez feels like a
lifetime ago it all is about that last
game and Yan naami the way he stood in
there he found his last chance in a bit
of a time crunch that is impressive he's
done it on multiple occasions now and as
you said you sort of make your own luck
they say better lucky than good I say
best great and lucky and that way is
what yand pishi is he survives he stays
alive the ches Masters
we've had so much action guys but
remember the main course is still to
come that was just the appetizer we have
Magnus Carlson entering the freay
against Dennis lazic and we cannot wait
but just before we go on a break I
wanted to mention that Opera and
chess.com have collaborated on the
internet browser for chess enthusiasts
the world's first chess browser has
chess integrated right into the sidebar
so you're only ever one click away from
a quick game of Blitz or a puzzle while
you work you can even pin the sidebar
panel open so that you can carry on
reading watching or browsing with one
eye on the board while your opponent
plots their next move this is available
for Windows Mac and Android use
exclamation point chess browser in the
chat now to download Opera for free take
it for a test ride we'll see you
soon we are going to see you very very
soon but use this time to download that
Opera browser get a bullet in because
you're going to need all that action for
the action that is coming up uh as we
head into the big Winners final we'll be
back with the 17-year-old Dennis lavic
taking on world number one Magnus
[Music]
bson
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twst twists
we present the next big new tournament
the freestyle chess goat challenge at
the Forefront of this epic chess
spectacle is none other than Magnus
Carlson the former world champion facing
his first duel with the reigning world
champion ding Len since his title
victory in addition to this top duel
Carlson has selected six other top
Challengers to make the tournament
especially exciting be sure to watch all
the games on the live stream at
chess.com and on our
freestyle-house-music-genre
[Music]
but some say that a new ruler will come
and restore the realm to its former
glory solve puzzles fight epic battles
and earn gold swords and Scrolls full of
Chess wisdom on your way to reclaiming
the throne download the app today and
this month only face off against your
favorite Kingdom character Bots only on
chess.com
[Music]
I am deeply offended by your porn eats
porn Rule I think that sort of thing is
cannibalism and Must Be Stopped let's
have a zoom discussion about
it and he includes the zoom link love
can we can we open that now is he there
that'd be great I I love the tone of
that like it's it's cannibalism let's
have a zoom discussion about it here's a
that is so good I was sure that was
going to be an on passant ticket you
know yeah I cannibalism yeah I thought
you we we were we were ready for ersan
he took us down a deep dark world of
cannibalism and here we are and by the
way I hope he's not waiting for us on
Zoom I wasn't even swearing in a mean
way I'm Australian it's how we
talk gronky wab be's walking about I'm
actually with him on that have you ever
talked to an Australian they drop an F
bomb like literally every other word and
I think you know one of the things we've
actually are working on now is that
friend chats have a different filter uh
so that if you're playing a friend you
know you can actually have engage in
some fun trash talking uh so that is
that is something we realistically are
are looking at because people deserve
that experience if they want Sean McCoy
bringing the knowledge didn't even know
that was a feature I love
it
n
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now walked right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar's going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God why an arm we
getting
welcome back everyone we hope you've
recovered from the absolutely insane
Armageddon Legend has it that Yana pami
and fosf are still analyzing what we
just witnessed that was one of the most
entertaining games I've seen on the tour
what a fight to the end but at the end
of it all Yi goes through fedos gets
knocked out for the action is on because
now we're off to the winnner final guys
we've got 17-year-old Dennis LA taking
on Magnus Carlson Magnus a big big
favorite Robert what are you expecting
from Dennis in this one I'm expecting
more of the same solid play from Dennis
the Menace he has done extraordinarily
well to this point in the chville
Masters in the placement he took down
aaru Nakamura and a girri then he beat
Maxim Vash grav and yesterday it was
Jose Martinez his latest victim so
Magnus Carlson he is the best player in
the world of Chess has been for the last
decade but why not you know you have to
rise to the occasion he's just a
teenager Dennis lazic he's proven that
he has what it takes to stick with the
best of them and meanwhile Magnus on his
part has eliminated Wesley saw and
Vladimir fed knocking both of them well
not eliminated but knocking both of them
in the losers bracket with some big wins
it's going to be a big fight David what
are your expectations from this finals
um well it's hard to look past Magnus
Carlson the world number one the
Champions chestor reigning uh winner and
uh I think he will bring his aame we
heard yesterday in the interview how
seriously Magnus is taking his young
opponent yes Dennis lazic is in the form
of his life but this is going to be a
whole different challenge so Magnus if
he can start fast if he has been taking
it as seriously uh as he said he would
then I think he is still the massive
massive favorite then again we all love
an underdog so Dennis lazovic let's hope
that he is able to at least hang in
there the first couple of games if he
does he will gain in confidence as well
um I just wait for the games to get
started uh expect the unexpected as we
always say on the
tour Dennis lazic has been making waves
in online chess he impressed us all in
the Champions chess store season 23 made
it to Toronto had a great performance
there held his own in many many games we
saw him in the world rapid and Blitz as
well playing with the very best just
some fantastic results there and then
this event it's been the event of his
career so far it almost feels like and
now the biggest hurdle he's playing the
boss fight now plays against Magnus
Dennis is ready to go Robert what are
the opening expectations from this one
solid openings from Dennis and who knows
from Magnus Carlson because nobody knows
what he's going to try out on a given
day sometimes he moves his rip Pawn on
the first turn so for Dennis he has been
a rising star for a while now and the
star is shining bright he is Dennis the
Conqueror look at the names of the
players he has taken down on his path
towards the winnner final Hikaru
Nakamura he needs no introduction anise
giri well that guy's pretty darn good at
chess too Maxim vashir lra so good that
he just goes by the three initials there
and is a former World blood Champion
Jose Martinez he may be world number 57
according to Fay rapid ratings but he's
much stronger than that just doesn't
play over the board all that much and
here well this is the best player on the
planet Magnus Carlson I am stoked to see
these two go out it because when they
went head-to-head over the board in
Toronto as the first moves are underway
Dennis Lazer was a few careful moves
away from making a draw in that first
game but ultimately it was Magnus who
came out on
top Magnus starts with the white pieces
uh Dennis is so strong with white
himself so Magnus will see this as a
chance to strike and he starts with the
English opening but already a pause here
um this is a bit of a surprising pause
for Magnus surely he's going to bring
out the other white knight or he's going
to push a pawn he's had this position
countless times before but Dennis is
well prepared already Magnus in the tank
for 30 seconds um Tanya the English
opening really part of magnus's Arsenal
but why is he thinking what is he
thinking about at this early stage I'm
as surprised as you are and while Magnus
thinks let's remind everyone on the
switch up the losers bracket is the best
of two the Winner's bracket is the best
of four this is the first game Magnus
perhaps just trying to think about what
kind of opening structure he wants now
to my knowledge David D3 is not the most
topical move very often white goes
Knight F3 wants to strike in the center
with D4 Magnus took his time is this
what he calls the anti- young player
chess I would say so uh just taking the
opponent out of the book giving them a
lot of choice giving them strategic
questions um like you say it's not one
of the main moves um actually I'm going
to eat my words this isn't the English
opening this is the Sicilian Defense
just with colors reversed and white has
an extra Tempo having started the game
first so um yeah Magnus he's hoping that
Dennis who isn't a one E4 player who
doesn't play Sicilians on the opposite
side he's hoping he's a bit
uncomfortable so black has gone for what
we would call an open Sicilian here it's
just kind of trading off Pawns in the
center White's going for what we would
call the Sicilian Dragon setup with the
beautiful Bishop on G2 and the game will
now proceed very very quickly look at
that Bishop a real sniper so many
Targets on that diagonal but Dennis has
reacted almost instantly since this
small surprise um I've got to say Robert
really impressive speed and Confidence
from the youngster impressive from
Dennis surprising from Magnus I'm not
sure what he's thinking about on each
and every turn this is a standard
looking position but from colors reverse
and I would imagine and he finally does
play Knight to F3 that that would be the
most olical continuation to the left of
our board we see the win percentages in
high level games stemming from this
opening and white does have a slight
lead but many of these games are drawn
and that's what Dennis lasic is known
for it sounds weird to say oh that kid
is known for drawing but really he just
doesn't lose very often it doesn't
matter who he's facing it doesn't matter
what color he has he rarely loses games
of Chess and that includes over theboard
tournaments at the highest level it
includes the Champions chess tour title
tu
he is super solid and this is anything
but solid from Magnus Knight to G5 I
mean he's playing some off feat kg chess
and if I'm Dennis I think I just occupy
the center I think I might want to bring
my knight up to D4 there oftentimes
tricks available if white isn't careful
on this E2 Square so I think that Magnus
he's uh just trying to catch Dennis off
guard but Tanya this is a still stable
stuff from the
17-year-old and that's what he known for
stable chess we've seen him we've seen
his games very few times you'd see
Dennis make some decisions that leave
him with a long-term weakness he really
likes to play these strategic fights to
me it was really fascinating what you
said earlier when Magnus went into an
early think that he's just trying to
think where can he go where Dennis might
not be too familiar and he takes this
reverse Sicilian setup up a move simply
because Dennis is not an E4 player
himself so perhaps trying to get him
into Waters where Dennis might not be
too familiar but I like the speed with
which he's played I like the fact that
Dennis has kept a position which doesn't
have weaknesses eventually we might even
see a light Square Bishop trade it
wasn't possible on the previous move
because the Knight on D5 was H was
hanging but if black is able to trade
off that E6 Bishop for the G2 Bishop
very often black solves all opening
problems because the one Trump that
Magnus has in this position is the
bishop bar Robert yes this bishop on D2
that's supposed to be a beneficial piece
but there aren't useful diagonals to
work with it's staring into its own
night there are actually no accessible
squares along the diagonal as I'm
putting them all in red because black
controls all of them so so far it's been
a stable game for both of these players
and Magnus as David said I think he
really called this correctly he's just
trying to get a bit of a longer game and
outplay Dennis later on and we already
can see that with a semi-open C file
there is some valuable Terrain in front
of this Rook especially if this Knight
moves out the way way David what do you
make of this move A5 I think it's clear
that's why Dennis has Fook at d8 but do
you like the setup that he is opting for
I think it's uh very sound as Tanya
mentioned that Dennis has limited
experience in this porn structure and uh
often if a player I know the viewers at
home might be thinking this as well if
you play a new opening if you're forced
into new ground it takes a while to
figure out where to put the pieces but
he's defending everything here Dennis
he's going for centralization the White
Queen the white uh sorry the black Queen
the Black Knights the black Bishop all
really well placed can't fault those and
now he's employing magnus's favorite
thing against him pushing Rooks pawns
just gaining space on the flanks it
always looks mysterious it always looks
like it's playing on kind of an
irrelevant side of the board but Pawn to
A5 if that black Bor pushes further
later on could become a real battering
ram it kind of takes away some of
White's major plans on the queen side
white normally would want to push pawns
A3 B4 so um yeah I think Dennis has
handled this really well it hasn't cost
him that much time on the clock he's
still within his comfort zone got
everything covered um like you were both
saying he's just this immovable object
Dennis the Conqueror no no it's Dennis
the Invincible as long as he doesn't
lose he's uh he's happy so um yeah I
think in terms of objective evaluation
he's solved all his problems he's
totally fine as black it's just about
later in the game whether he can kind of
uh maintain that composure when Magnus
inevitably does start to ask some
difficult questions starting with this
move Quint A4 um Robert a bit tactic
suspect a queen on A4 often but here it
looks like it's fine for white yeah
typically you take advantage of a queen
over here on A4 with tactics along the
diagonal loose pieces drop off you
always have to consider what happens if
the piece in between hops out the way I
want to show very quick variation so
let's bring up the analysis board
because some players might be looking
for tactics on this diagonal but Knight
takes C3 removing the guard of the queen
after B takes C3 let's say you hop in
with a knight to D4 I thought the
evaluation would go all the way up in
White's face favor but apparently it's
not that bad Knight takes E2 check
intermetzo was the point the king slides
to the corner Rook takes D7 I thought
that this Knight was just trapped on E2
and it does look trapped but amazingly
this is ridiculous the move that black
has here is Bishop to C4 see this and
then to properly assess I get it that
you can't take the bishop because the
bishop on D2 is loose but to consider
this position here where at the end of
things white has two Bishops for a rook
and apparently it's just level uh this
is a rook in two pawns for two Bishops
yeah it's a mess but Dennis maybe if he
calculates this deep he can go for this
variation I thought it was impossible
but clearly there is a lot that's going
on here that does not immediately catch
the
eye but very often Robert it's not just
about calculating these kind of
variations but also evaluating that
final position as something that you
want on the board which can be very
challenging because to me looking at
that two Bishop versus Rook sure the
computer might say it's level but from a
human perspective you're never really
sure because the Bishops can be super
strong against The Rook so it's also
something that perhaps Dennis isn't
forced to go so he's trying to think of
many many different options it's the
kind of position where chess is a
complicated game you can have different
approaches different plans we see the
move Queen to A4 and Dennis needs to
think what pieces to trade maybe he
trades maybe he doesn't maybe he sidest
steps with the queen but he is taking
his time right now David what would be
your approach with black in this
position um I think I wouldn't go for
that line just because uh I'd probably
be too lazy to calculate in a rapid game
but also partly because as Robert said
it's so difficult to uh evaluate and wow
Dennis he's just traded off the night I
believe Knight takes Knight we're
heading in that direction Dennis he's so
good strategically for such a young
player really mature his kind of
decision making his end game skills but
also very sharp in terms of tactics so I
wouldn't have been surprised if he did
play Knight D4 but this is the
justification he didn't need to enter
those murky Waters it's not his
character he just wants to trade off
light Square Bishops as you pointed out
Tanya and he's doing it in a different
fashion but probably equally effective
white doesn't really want to run away or
block this light Square Bishop trade
because that would really hamper the
activity of White's Bishops um I think
Dennis has made a good decision and if
we're left with just queen of Knight
versus queen of Bishop as we've kind of
touched upon before that Dynamic can
favor the side with the Knight so um
yeah again it cost him a lot of time two
three minutes Dennis but as we've come
to expect from him Robert always a sound
positional decision from him and
speaking of well unsound positional
decisions Pawn to F3 from Magnus the
evaluation part doesn't really budge so
objectively this is a good call actually
think practically it is too because
black had a clear plan let's trade
Bishops I do want to point out that the
tactic I was noting before Knight D4 can
always be met by Queen to D1 to defend
that loose Pawn on E2 here you could
successfully trade Queens but I just
want to note that that was not a forc
variation but after F3 there isn't
anything forced for black now Dennis has
to make another difficult decision and
what is the actual plan Tanya I actually
I'm appreciating this move from Magnus
he is just keeping everything under
control on his end and saying to Dennis
what are you going to do I have the
bishop hair and in the long run the
Bishops May Flex their might on the
diagonals keeping more tension on the
board if the Bishops are traded off it
really helps black in the position the
Knight better than that Bishop it just
makes things so much easier F3
eventually black needs to take a
decision because Black's Bishop on D5
isn't very stable it can be kicked out
it might even fall back maybe F3 is a
move that Dennis actually provoked to
block that Bishop but look at that last
move by Dennis he clears up another
Square on C6 for his own Bishop he
really wants to keep it on this diagonal
making sure that he can neutralize the
bishop pair that white has I saw the
evalar it did not approve of this queen
trade but from a human perspective it
looks like a very practical choice to
make
David yeah it makes sense getting the
Queens off it simplifies things somewhat
but this is kind of Magnus playing anti-
young player chess you mentioned it that
phrase Tanya while I was off camera I
quickly got out the Oxford dictionary I
checked what that meant and it's pretty
much getting the Queens off don't allow
your young opponent any fun and any
activity you take the long-term
advantages here Magnus has the bishop
pair we've talked about and also the
extra Central Pawn and uh with all of
those small imbalances you try to tire
out your young opponents and uh of
course Dennis is no ordinary upster it's
no guarantee that it will work but I
think this is Magnus again as Robert
mentioned just kind of asking small
questions later he'll again start
creating threats start pushing the white
pawns which pawns will he push who knows
Dennis isn't sure either so Dennis will
have to burn time watching out for moves
like F4 in the near future and um yeah I
I don't really like the fact that you
trade traded Queens yes it made things
more simple but remember Bishop pairs
gaining power the longer the game goes
on the more the board clears up so uh
this end game I would think against
anyone in the world it would be a bit
more one-sided um Magnus is on the white
side but yeah Dennis if he proves yet
again as he has done this whole week
that he can hang in these tight end
games against the world's best then he
will deserve uh this result F7 what do
we think of that robot I like that move
from Dennis at some moment he can
consider bringing his Bishop back to D7
and F4 that's the big idea for Magnus
creating a pawn break but perhaps Dennis
won't allow the pure break and will push
himself to E4 just trying to ask
questions to White's Pawn structure so
so far there hasn't been pieces staring
at one another we're just seeing some
maneuvering but I do still think that
White's plans are easier and it's in
part because there are more pawns for
white in the center we see two pawns for
white one on D3 one on E2 just one for
black and we have lovely Pawn chains for
black the pawns are a bit scattered and
I do think that at some point white will
play F4 you just have to time it
correctly and meet E4 with D4 so tell
you I think that Magnus he's in a
quintessential Magnus
position you've put it really well and I
don't think there's anything scarier
than playing Magnus in these kind of end
games where mere Mortel like us might be
like this you know eventually we'll
fizzle out into a draw one of the minor
pieces might get traded off no
weaknesses for black matus Carlson is
already smelling blood here he's got the
bishop pair he's looking longterm he's
placed his rook in B1 F4 always in the
air although the last move by Dennis I
like it he puts that pawn on B6 you want
to place as many pawns on the dark
squares to limit the activity of that
dark Squad Bishop that Magnus has
because that's the bishop that Dennis is
lacking in the position he's moved the H
I won't be surprised if you might see G5
on the board as well trying to restrict
that F4 break that you were earlier
alluding to uh Robert it's far from over
but playing against Magnus this is this
can be a terrifying position uh
David yeah for sure um this position
actually did appear on page 83 of
growing like a Grandmas so Magnus has
studied it before and pawn to F4 Robert
it's this big question what to do black
has to break the beautiful Pawn chain
that black has from G7 to E5 you have to
make a decision now to block it lock it
or just try to I was about to say
maintain the status quo but you can't he
does indeed push his paorn forward what
do you make of these changes in
structure well I do like how quickly
Dennis is responding uh he is trying to
control the light Square so if the
Bishops had been traded then that Knight
would have just hopped into F5 but for
now that Knight on E7 it's a bit
restricted pie is fighting for the same
squares I won't be surprised if Magnus
uses his King but don't rush a decision
like that because at some moment black
can strike pushing this E Pawn forward
but if this white king I'm just going to
teleport it on over to E3 this is a
problem for black in many of these
positions I'm just you know hovering the
king over the square I'm blockading I'm
putting pressure on your E4 Pawn so this
E4 Pawn the main point is overextended
atan I still don't see easy plans for
Dennis he's shuffling back and forth the
engine isn't suggesting it's a winning
Advantage for Magnus nothing of the sort
but he just his moves is always easier
to play I think D just has to wait right
now he has to keep shuffling with the
Rooks like you mentioned keep the
position as is and let Magnus show what
is his improving technique here he plays
the move E3 so making sure that black
doesn't have that E Pawn push anymore
which at the right time would have
activated that Bishop gets the other
Rook into the game to me it's really
impressive the speed with which Dennis
is responding a position that's slightly
passive for him because for Magnus he's
playing not only the board but also
Dennis's clock so Dennis needs to make
sure that he has those extra seconds
that extra minute when those critical
decisions will have to be made and they
will come when you'll have to decide
which pawns to trade which pawns to push
in this position do you ever want to
make a move like G5 do you just want to
stay still so there are some big
decisions ahead on the road for Dennis I
like his speed David how do you think
you know Magnus best what do you think
is going on in his mind right now how
does he see this being played out Magnus
is just calculating I think he's turned
off the emotions here it feels like
Magnus has upped his game from yesterday
where there was a a bit of inconsistency
there are a few slip UPS here and there
he's just gone back to basics Magnus
kind of 1.0 the Magnus who first break
broke onto the scene where it's just
about grinding himself and kind of look
at this Pawn to C5 now undermining
Black's stronghold on the queen side I
think this is Magnus zeroing in you
mentioned being oppressed by Dennis the
speed T I was too but suddenly I look at
the clock and he's a minute and a half
down suddenly the black queenside on the
verge of collapse uh so yeah it feels
like Magnus is again keeping things
simple Rook to B2 there just covering
the A2 Pawn soon the white light Square
Bishop will come into the game there we
go it reroots itself and yeah I've got
to say I'm very biased towards the white
position right now it looks like black
is just really tied up defending
everything and no active plans um where
the Breakthrough is who knows uh Magnus
and Dennis both know better than I do
but right now it does look like White's
advantage only growing kind of
incrementally step by- step Rober every
single move and this Pawn on A5 is just
such a problem piece for black to deal
with if this Pawn were back on A7 you'd
feel like you'd a healthier structure
for now the Knight on C8 can't easily
get out because you might drop the B6
Pawn you don't want to take on C5
because then A5 will drop so here it's
about making that incremental progress
that we're talking about Bishop to E2 at
some moment to also play G4 further
expansion but if you start trading pawns
it gives the black Rooks some file so I
love the way Magnus continues to play
his Rooks have chance I don't care about
that question get out of here with that
that's not a question mark move and I
don't even know what black should do to
respond it says Black's best move here
yeah it was gonna be played Knight to E7
giving away this B6 Pawn so if that's
the way to get out of it you're not
finding that as a human with one minute
and 15 seconds on your clock Magnus is
doing everything right in my opinion he
controls this
board look at that last move Pawn A3
he's in Zero Rush at all again
instructed for everyone at home when you
have a long-term Advantage when there's
no immediate threats from your opponent
you don't need to rush just slowly
improve he's freed up that white Rook on
B2 now it will no longer be tied down to
that pawn as Robert mentioned at some
point he might even play King to G2 to
defend the white H3 Pawn uh kind of let
the light Square Bishop loose to start
playing and Denis every single move he's
asked with a question what are you doing
how do you improve black Camp cannot
improve his position cannot create any
threats and that burns time on the clock
look at this 30 seconds Tanya the time
situation it looked under control but
suddenly no longer it's always so
impressive how easy Magnus makes these
end games look he has this unique
ability to combine all these different
aspects in the position he first
advances on the king side gains the
space slowly improves the king puts the
Rooks on the correct SC uh the correct
files which potentially long-term can
open up so they're ideally played
meanwhile Black's Rook doubled on the D
line but they're undermined by that D4
Pawn The Bishop's coming into play small
moves like A3 forcing Dennis to make a
move which is much harder when you lack
spaces and for Magnus Carlson it just
feels like the Magnus magic when it
comes to these end games and look at him
on the camera he looks so incredibly
confident and now Dennis has to hold
this position with is 20 seconds on the
clock complete control from Magnus
Carlson every single little move a pawn
push to get off the dagine by the way
Dennis is getting really low on time and
that's when the mistakes happen
Advantage growing and Bishop E2 a
correct response keeping that King
Frozen opening the CNB files but where
is The Knockout there must be something
here or at least in the near future as
Dennis is under 10 seconds David and
there we go Magnus opens up a second
front of attack he's already probed away
on Black's Left Flank now he's switching
focus and hoping to overwhelm the black
Army and wow every move suddenly it's
King side then Queen side King side and
queen side and there we go Rook C6 he's
infiltrated Enemy Lines he's into the
sixth rank that black knight is so sad
right now Dennis's time situation sad as
well eight seconds left it's on the
brink of collapse as you say Robert
still yet to uh kind of click that
Domino flick it and uh for everything to
start toppling but Magnus is looking for
the Breakthrough um and yeah here there
so many tempting moves right now for
white lot of tempting moves and it's
also so instructive how Magnus kept
improving his position made these small
moves and only went for the G4 break
when Dennis was down to seconds because
it's such a difficult move to respond to
and he might give a check on C4 right
now I don't believe you can fall back
with the bishop I'm already looking at
ideas like the D Pawn moving forward and
that would have been tactics I would
have worked in magnus's favor it just
looks like Black's pieces are losing
Harmony right now The Rook is active the
Knight on C8 there has to be something
really strong right now can white start
thinking about advancing the D Pawn does
he put pressure on the C8 Knight what's
the move here too many good options I'm
actually not sure nor is Magnus and
that's why he's doing the right thing
he's slowing down he pushes his Pawn to
D5 it opens up a diagonal for the dark
Square Bishop but look at Dennis he is
hanging in there he may have seven
seconds left but his last few moves have
been solid Magnus is like how do I
actually win this game because if Dennis
gets his Knight out watch out mean
suddenly this becomes a bit messy and
White's King is feeling a little bit
lonely there could be checks against it
and things of that
nature Denis he's so resourceful we wow
Magnus sacrifices The Exchange I was
about saying Dennis NY never loses
because he defends better than most
players in the world and suddenly he's
oh he's given up another Pawn on the A5
Square magnus's D Pawn looks huge he
played that last move with three seconds
left Dennis it might be the crunch of
time trouble here a pin he needs to
react he defends his Bishop magnus's
Bishops are going to become moners there
we go another Pawn drops it's bishop and
two pawns for the rook and a check has
Magnus seized it now Dennis shaking his
head Robert he's on the brink yes a win
for Magnus Carlson resignation but it
was time that did Dennis lazic in you
see the last move a brilliant one giving
up his Rook for Bishop because the other
Rook was threatened but look at Magnus
quickly turns off his camera he wants a
little bit of a break and for Dennis
lazik there are no breaks you're playing
Magnus Carlson in the best of four match
the first the two and a half wins and
Magnus Carlson gets game one Dennis Les
has to score a win he can't just draw
out anymore I think Dan is just sitting
there trying to think what went wrong
because it's that kind of a game that
you see from start to finish and you
can't even point out where did it all go
so wrong for black Maus just seemed to
outplay him move by move slowly
converting another Magnus Masterpiece in
the end game David uh that one a true
piece for grind like a
grandm Magnus got the job done in the
end but it got a bit shaky Dennis did
get his chances towards the end so we
have to credit the youngster there for
defending tenaciously not panicking
ultimately though it was the combined
psychological pressure of facing Magnus
it was the board it was the clock and uh
yeah that was close I actually thought
suddenly we would see a turnaround there
and now it's just about how Dennis
recovers that was his first loss of the
whole of division one so far um only his
second of the chess ball Masters if we
count the the play uh so Dennis he's
pretty much a new terrain new territory
great fight from him but when you're
playing the world number
one tough Magnus looked ruthless there
um Robert what do you make of the second
game Dennis with white he's known to be
strong he's known to be strong but
Magnus Carlson is known to be the
strongest so for Dennis lack you know he
was in a worst spot Magnus show
tremendous restraint and then he kind of
bullet chest him where Magnus had too
much time so Dennis lvic he trots out
his typical stuff and perhaps one of the
issues for Dennis is because he's such a
solid player he doesn't go off the
beaten path and he needs to take some
risk David you talked about a lot
yesterday from fedos se's perspective to
beat Magnus Carlson you don't want to
just play with a slight little advantage
and hope that Magnus goes wrong you have
to ask him really difficult questions do
you think this opening is actually one
that Magnus scares is scared of in the
least not yet Dennis might have to add
some Spice in the near future uh I've
been lucky enough to play Magnus in
hundreds of Blitz Games and uh yeah as
you mentioned just there the only way
that he ever goes wrong as if it's a
totally irrational position where all of
us go wrong uh he is human but if you
give him a positional Advantage like we
saw in that previous game he's
Unstoppable Magnus Garson uh so here
Dennis he's going on the attack that
white knight jump attacked the black
Dart Square Bishop um this came from a
semi slav defense now a trade of Bishops
oh Magnus looks well prepared because
he's kicking the White Knight back is
isolated Queen Pawn territory now and
black offering a trade of Bishops long
term it would uh at least conventional
wisdom would say that white is better
but Magnus has clearly studied this
before Tanya another default opening um
what do you make of the outcome here I'm
just amazed with the speed with which
the players are playing I'm not familiar
with this particular this exact position
Bishop G4 usually they say that when
you've got the isolated Queen Pawn you
should avoid trades but I think the
reason that Magnus is going for Bishop
G4 is because white is still behind in
development and actually taking that
bishop and G4 would have allowed Black's
Knight to jump forward and potentially
the queen to come out into activity
really quickly manness seems to know
exactly what he's doing in this position
and while D5 is a longterm weakness now
with provoking F3 E3 also becomes a
tender spot in White's position that's
absolutely correct and Magnus when
Dennis lazik played F3 was kind of like
hm this looks a bit odd to me but I
think he respected it because instead of
just trading off pieces it shows that
Dennis is trying to fight but the
problem here in this position is Dennis
he Retreats his Knight a defensive move
is that you need to you know find a
square to hop into you need to find a
Target to exploit normally that D5 Pawn
would be the issue but Black's one
Knight covers it and white can't easily
increase the attack against it so I love
the way that Magnus has handled it I
think he could slide his Rook to C8 as
well to force this Queen off the the
open line but for both of these players
it's going to be about who comes up with
the Better plan because I think most of
their pieces are optimally placed at the
moment
least and uh Dennis as we mentioned felt
to defeat in that previous game but he's
really raced out of the traps here he's
still got 9 minutes 20 he's made some
big decisions the youngster um I'm going
to say impressive composure to just uh
recover so quickly to not go uh into any
long thinks early in the game trademark
move there from Magnus gson again
mysterious Rooks Pawn push gaining space
stopping white from Gaining uh kind of
territory on that side of the board
watch out for that H paorn to play a
role a bit later it always seems to when
it's Magnus gson but in the meantime
Dennis I think in terms of a long game
here which is pretty much guaranteed to
be he would love to trade off the Queens
as white he would love to maybe trade
off a set or two of Rooks and uh slowly
but surely try to improve the white
pieces it's all about one problem piece
one bad piece makes a whole position bad
they say and White's Knight on F1 not
making a great impression right now um
but yeah it's still anyone's game it's
still a long way to go at least uh Tanya
compared to the previous game Dennis
doesn't have long-term issues here to
worry
about yeah but he might have short-term
issues to worry about with the hbond
moving forward now black taking control
of the SE file we might even see a
potential idea you said these are
magnus's uh thematic moves of trying to
go trademark moves maybe we might even
see an A5 A4 at some point trying to
undermine queenside last game we saw him
play on the king side and the queen side
controlling the board but right now it
looks like Magnus just wants to trade
off as many pieces now traditional
wisdom is that again the more pieces
that get traded off the side that's
playing against the isolated Queen Pawn
white in this case if he was white why
is Magnus so happy to trade these pieces
off Robert in this particular position
it's because he can't and he being
Dennis can't put the pawn back on F2 and
that's why his King went out here that a
Pawn's best friend is another Pawn you
want to keep little Pawn chains here and
there so that you don't have to use more
valuable pieces to defend them the
Knight on F1 that's not where it really
wants to be it's defending this Pawn on
E3 but the king jumps out to F2 I like
your idea Tanya A5 play A4 just create a
pawn break on the other flank because
there's a lot of tension in the center
and you could start trading pieces there
but white does have control of that open
file and okay Magnus he plays H5 he
plays A5 he is playing perfect chess in
this game I know Dennis is playing well
too but normally we talk about white
pressing for an advantage I I don't feel
like Dennis has anything that he can
strike at and so Magnus he's really
handling this
perfectly you know what I find the most
annoying thing in chess uh guys it's
knowing magnus' style knowing what he's
going to play but somehow not being able
to replicate his results his success
it's it's crazy we knew H5 was coming we
knew A5 was coming probably Dennis knew
it too but what do you do against it
it's just the timing it's just the sense
the feeling and yeah Magnus he's got
ideas like Pawn to A4 just disrupting
white over there Queen to B4 even at
some point might be in kind of a factor
trading off Queens but on Black's terms
and the central tension why break it why
uh kind of make things more simple here
for Dennis Dennis now going into a
longer think because it's so tense and
that is psychologically tough when
you're facing a juggernaut like Magnus
um so I think get the impression at
least that we're slightly favoring
Black's chances or at least the trend
for black but uh Dennis he needs to
somehow make his Mark I think most
importantly he needs to not lose this
game just even a draw wouldn't be the
worst result gain a bit of confidence
against Magnus but uh a tough spot for
the youngster right
now absolutely and Dennis we've been so
full of Praise of his style which
predominantly is extremely strong
positional strategic understanding but
when you're playing against Magnus we've
often seen we saw at the AI cup when
Maxim did it he beat Magnus twice in the
Grand Final to take it that very often
you need to create these messy chaotic
complicated positions and I think that
is just something that's not intuitively
Dennis's style and then how do you
outplay a player like Magnus or try to
create chances in a positional battle we
saw the same narrative in game one these
slow moves by white when Magnus played
just slowly improving position and you
didn't even understand where it all went
wrong for Dennis and I'm getting that
same exact feeling in this one H5 A5 not
sure why white went wrong but I'm liking
Black's position
already I don't think that white went
wrong really at all I think that F3 move
did catch Magnus by surprise because it
gave Magnus a Target to look at but the
way Magnus plays in positions like this
it's tremendous understanding that H5 it
didn't necessarily carry this punch to
it you think H5 you're going for an
alpha zero like attack go Checkmate
something like that no it's just it's
restricting white David made this point
earlier that in many of these positions
white likes to expand because the white
king is actually quite safe out in the
open to play a move like G4 unavailable
this move A5 is he going to play A4 or
is he just trying to give his Knight a
square of safety on B4 maybe even Queen
B4 at some point because when you trade
and take back with the pawn this Rook
can slide to an open file I know these
are some deeper Concepts but Magnus
Carlson truly understands the the ins
and outs of these positions and here's
another example you could take with his
Bishop on C6 you could take with the
pawn on C6 he takes with the pawn which
I do think is the best play but it
changes the dynamic where now the
eyesight Pawn is on A5 there a backward
Pawn on C6 and now Queen trade is on
offer David are you swapping Queens here
if you're Magnus or are you going to
avoid that for now the
Swap and Magnus takes I'm actually
surprised I was actually going to say
the opposite like uh here it felt like
White's King potentially slightly more
vulnerable than its counterpart so
keeping Coen on in that regard uh tends
to favor you uh potential attacking
chances but Magnus he's at least
guaranteed that both sides have three
Pawn Islands here not only does black
have an isolated Pawn on A5 but White's
Central Pawn on D4 now um lacking any uh
real support so I'm surprised purely in
the fact that uh White has outposts now
like The Rook on C5 but
ultimately it's just the fact that the
White Knight is so bad that I think
Magnus can get away with this and he's
confident that he will at least hold the
ensuing end game um I still very
surprised it shows that Magnus doesn't
necessarily want to win this game I
think he's happy now to try and guide
this towards safety guide it towards a
draw But ultimately yeah a sound
decision that was a matter of taste and
Magnus maybe just wants to hold this one
strike with white yet again in the next
game uh Tanya do you see Dennis
potentially winning this some day does
he have any chances at
all I think it would be really
impressive if Dennis is just able to
stop the bleeding I think this is still
a very level position the reason I say
that is because there's always this
counterplay on the queen side with A4 at
the right moment right now Magnus is
line it up with Rook B8 and I think he
has A4 in his mind because it looks like
a pawn sacrifice but taking that pawn
it's only temporary black can even start
attacking it with Rook eight but also
get Super Active with the move Rook to
B2 that you're pointing out so with this
Queens side looking like it's going to
be neutralized it's going to be
liquidated I think draw is the most
likely result what do you think Robert I
never trust anybody to draw against
Magnus Carlson in an end game I'm
serious the amount of times we've seen
him win that look like unwinable
positions everyone else would have
agreed to a draw dozens of moves earlier
he outlasts his opponent and the side
that controls the pawn breaks is often
the side with the advantage here I see a
very simple Pawn break from the black
side I don't see the same from White yes
I can create some Pawn tension excuse me
with Pawn to G4 but after a swap of
Pawns you're just giving black some key
squares in the center of the board so A4
is actually a big threat Rook B4 at some
moment can also be annoying as David
point out white has an isolated Pawn to
take care of so what next for Dennis
lazic because he dips under three
minutes he is the one in immense time
trouble I don't think Magnus is playing
this for a draw I think he is looking
for those Chan is an A4 is certainly a
big
one and the the clock you mentioned it
there Robert it really reflects the ease
of plans not just in end games in
openings middle games often the top
players they don't necessarily look for
uh an advantage the computer says is
plus 0.4 0.5 they would rather take a
position that is level but their plans
are straightforward easy U you've been
pointing out Pawn A4 Rook to B4 Black's
King is coming if you need on autopilot
Black's King is coming to E7 D6 what is
white doing in the meantime Dennis is
yet to figure it out I don't see any
obvious moves either two minutes now
against almost eight yeah Magnus will
definitely get ambitious if this trend
continues Rook C5 forcing blacks reply
but now A4 even more uh tempting within
the next few moves Dennis really needs
to pick up the pace maybe the nerves now
this huge occasion is getting to him
T we started this with 10 minutes as
base time Magnus is at 7 minutes and 57
seconds the the clock situation says
everything that needs to be said about
this Dennis is on the defense in this
one and Magnus is going to play this out
till the end Dennis still has to earn
the draw and I was a lot more hopeful
about that draw just uh just a couple of
minutes ago but after seeing the clock
situation I agree with both of you I
think Magnus is ambitious in this one
there's been nothing flashy about this
game you just saw the scorecard beneath
the players is saying that there were no
brilliant moves there were no really
moves as deserving exclamation points
just because it's been an even battle
you see the accuracy 99.1 for Magnus
Carlson and not to shabby 98.7 from
Dennis lasic the problem for Dennis is
it's taking him a lot of time to play
nearly perfect chess for Magnus his
moves now are more natural and he's been
playing the start of this game extremely
quickly so look at every turn from
Magnus the Knight on F6 dominated by OPP
on F3 let's reroute that pony here comes
the Knight where where's it going Knight
D6 maybe Knight C7 to E
here it comes watch out for the isolated
D Pawn I am worried about Dennis lai's
position he's doing a great job of
keeping up the accuracy but the way
Magnus is playing and the speed with
which he's playing and look at his face
he just doesn't look bothered he's just
like okay yeah okay and just another end
game I'm gonna get this one David he's
grinding like a grandm if I've ever seen
someone do it exactly he's uh just
improving every single move those black
pieces are getting better and better I
wouldn't be surprised if he plays to
move Pawn to G6 now just just to cut out
any jumps to the F5 Square there we go
on the board this is just typical Magnus
he's not playing complicated moves
anyone's capable of playing these moves
given a bit of time but he's just doing
it confidently quickly and um I mean
I've read an interview recently about
his world rapid Championship triumphs
and why he's so successful over the
other players he said he admits it's
because he's able to maintain kind of uh
this Tempo and uh he kind of trusts his
instincts he knows when to switch the
pace when to start improving just kind
of go through this maneuvering phase and
then switch to start hustling the
opponent and I'm waiting for that moment
to start now 45 seconds against 7
minutes 30 he's going to start creating
threats in the near future trust me
Magnus and uh it's just about whether
Dennis can keep reacting he's held
everything together so far still great
accuracy 98.3 but it's only going to get
more difficult with every single move
Tanya it feels like it's all in Black's
favor white pieces are not better than
they were five six moves ago Magnus is
certainly are
so instructive the way Magnus has played
this one out and once again the break
will come it might be A4 might be
something on the king side it will come
and it will be when Dennis is down on
the clock playing to seconds forcing him
to take a critical decision when he's
got no time on the clock and there it is
with 30 seconds on the clock Dennis
lazovic needs to decide what to do in an
extremely difficult end game look at
magnus's clock 7 minutes to boot once
again a master class on end game by
Magnus gson and Perfect Defense so far
from Dennis lavic but perfect can be the
enemy of the good he does not have time
to continue calculating here he's
brought his King and his Bishop to the
defense of the B Pawn at some point
watch out for move like C5 springing
free that one time isolated pawn it may
be isolated once again but that's also a
pass Pawn so Dennis has some tactics to
look out for he has some positional
weaknesses but he is doing the right
thing so credit to the youngster uh I
would have collapsed moves ago he is
hanging in tough in the evaluation bar
it's not budging because he's playing
accurately well done but the challenge
continues because Magnus hey he's
Magnus Dennis yeah I was raving about
magnus's end game play Dennis he's great
in this department I think that's why
we're so amazed by him why he's been so
successful especially in uh this these
time formats rapid and Blitz because
he's got such good instincts even with
20 seconds on the clock now he's finding
the right squares for his pieces he's
not allowed his weaknesses to be
attacked too easily he's holding
everything together and actually if
there is a trade of Pawns on the B3
Square which is very likely white will
potentially be left with a pass Aon he's
got chances of his own so Dennis he's
been doing the right thing Magnus Now
using his time Advantage by pausing
sensing a critical moment again another
trait of a top player and um yeah it's
just about whether he can continue to
probe away and kind of trick Dennis
potentially in the near future the the
way this is going it is black asking the
questions but Dennis has all the answers
so yeah just high high quality chest
there we go a trade of Pawns and the
bishop recaptures Magnus selling traps
look at this a loose White Knight loose
piece drop off Dennis under 20 seconds
he's got to react
now oh Tanya is hanging by a threat
already Rook to E1 looks a bit scary for
white tactically so sharp as well Dennis
he sensed it he knew that there's an
attack on the night Magnus immediately
played rookie it putting pressure on the
clock and then is rightly replied by
defending that Knight on E3 placing his
own Rook on that e file the pressure is
on and we've been talking about how
Denis has been handling it so well
hasn't collapsed while many of the top
players would have by now against Magnus
especially but the thing is that this is
incremental slowly the pressure builds
on move by move it's really it just gets
more and more difficult to be accurate
I'm just going to be so impressed if
Dennis manages to hold this he's already
impressed all of us but this will be to
a whole different level if if he manages
to draw this one well you use the word
incremental it's fortunate for Den lack
there is increment in this game because
he gains two seconds with every move
that he plays so if he can pre-move and
play in one millisecond then he will get
time to rebuild on his clock as he's
doing right now at Knight E3 it's given
an exclamation point I think it's the
first one we've seen today it was
absolutely necessary if a knight gets to
F5 there is some trouble Brewing on the
white king side so so far Magnus he's
going left he's going right he's
bringing his Rook to the center and all
the way back but he has not made any
progress just yet but for Dennis he
needs to continue to find these accurate
defenses at some point I think Magnus he
may strike with the c Pawn but David if
you strike too soon it can backfire oh I
be see
R you said it that the position that was
the second time we've seen that Magnus
plays for the win though if he brought
his Rook back to E8 we might have been
on for a draw there but no it's like an
exam for Dennis he's 17 he should be
doing exams he's being asked so many
questions Pawn A4 there he's stopping
the black knight from activating with a
check still 11 seconds it feels like
time's disappearing so much faster uh
Knight to E6 now Magnus is just going
round in circles not actually doing too
much but every move there's a hidden
idea that Dennis has to react to 11
seconds we're going to keep talking
about the clock because right now it is
the most relevant Factor look at this
Magnus opening a second front again PA
to
G5 and one and Magnus Carlson brings the
break when his opponent is down to
seconds has to take a decision he's
attacking the G3 Pawn but in return he
can simplify he can take on H5 uh give a
check many ideas on the board can he
actually just
go wow because of Knight F5 yeah find by
Dennis no don't apologize I think right
now Magnus he might need to apologize
for continuing to press because he may
have tricked himself Knight to E3 and
protects the pawn tactically speaking H5
can be captured now G3 can because the
bishop covered F5 but is Dennis Laz
playing for a
win oh the evaluation B really went on
white side there and Magnus reacted on
the camera what had he missed maybe
Magnus realizing that Bishop to A6 uh is
simply going to be blocked now trying to
hit that white knight is going to be
blocked by White's light Square bishop
and Magnus has the weakest Pawn of them
all magnus's H5 Pawn might just drop off
it's definitely Dennis playing for the
win applying the pressure he's a pawn up
he's a PA up against the world number
one this has changed so quickly Magnus
needs to pull the break now and try to
draw it's not going to be easy though
this is a check Dennis six seconds left
but he's
better but there are tricks on the board
the A4 Pawn is hanging I don't see a
good way to defend that and Dennis going
for Black's King trying to get active
with his own Knight Knight F5 check
coming in uh first Magnus grabs the pawn
the Knight jumps in the F7 Pawn is a
weakness and can be a big Target I think
Dennis can start aiming for more here
this is going to be a bit of a pawn race
because black can take D4 white takes F7
and it's even material but we have two
sets of two pass pawns one for black in
the center here with C6 and D5 and white
will have fngg pawns it's usually good
to have outermost pass pawns because
they're harder to track down but this
becomes anyone's contest and the good
news for Magnus Carlson as many fans is
he's got plenty of time but for Dennis
lvic what a Speed Demon he
is I think everyone's becoming a Dennis
lazovic fan David what incredible play
by him and he's going for it he wants
that pawn race he wants to trade the D4
Pawn for the F7 Pawn it's game on David
Iman look at this the pawn race begins
black snaps off a pawn black has two
connected passes in the center but
White's f and g pawns will run super
fast wherever the black Rook goes next
move it has to move has to save itself
white is going to snap off that pawn on
F7 yes the evaluation Bar says equal but
this is far from a dead drawn end game
this is a 50/50 a total coin toss about
who's going to be quicker here wh's
pawns just push them he gives a check
first of all Dennis Magnus
hides maybe if white pushes forward will
Magnus snap that porn off I was going to
say he could have taken it forced a draw
but uh Magnus playing for the win Dennis
under 10
seconds Robert I'm funny this so hard to
predict every move it feels like it
could turn this Fe chat right now is
spot on Dennis is playing brilliantly he
is not going to bow down to the number
one rated player in the world and this
is a g Pawn that is running to the other
side and it's hard to stop the black
king is in the way of your own C Pawn
you would like to push the outermost
pass Pawn so Magnus and this isn't that
simple sure he can bring his King in and
that actually looks a bit worrisome but
I think this Pawn on C6 can it they grab
Dennis answers the question immediately
because Black's Bishop under
attack great spot Dennis lavic he's
basically secured himself safety now and
Black's Bishop attack gives itself up
for the highest price we're seeing this
fizzle out to a dead drone Rook end game
now Magnus you can see on the camera he
knows no more winning chances this is
guaranteed to be a draw Dennis has
fought Magnus toe-to-toe on magnus's
home territory and held the balance we
see the position repeat itself and a
draw unbelievable what a Hold by danis
laig this is beyond impressive by the
17-year-old who played majority of the
game under 20 seconds on pressure every
single move finding the resources he's
impressed us a lot of times I have never
been more impressed than I am right now
with that draw against Magnus Carlson no
amount of Praise Robert is enough right
now for Dennis lazic that is certainly
the case because normally we're shouting
to the skies about winds and how great
that tactic was but that defense oh
goodness you don't just find that on the
streets that is amazingly impressive
it's hard work it's persistence and that
was 98% accuracy most of which was done
with under 20 seconds on the clock so
Dennis La he may be trailing right now
but Magnus Carlson is looking at him
like wow this guy does not break he is a
star he's just 17 years old and he was
able to withstand all of that pressure
so David I don't know how he does it
that was seriously
incredible that was yes another level
that was like seeing Magnus against mini
Magnus uh not many people can fight
Magnus in that type of position let
alone with five six seconds on the clock
and I just wanted to praise Dennis's
calm uh composure at this moment here
after a lot of Maneuvers Magnus Strikes
Out by playing the move Pawn to G5 a lot
of us would have panicked here after
this move for example taking this porn
now would have ended really badly for
white potentially this is a big weakness
the G Pawn would have been a big
weakness after the black Rook swung
instead Dennis found a nice resource he
did not capture this Pawn he brought his
Rook across and uh yes the computer
might have been harsh about it but it
was this moment not reacting to this
Pawn being attacked not getting greedy
and taking this black pawn instead
finding a night jump a night Fork coming
into F5 the pawn is Untouchable and a
few moves later we saw actually Dennis
start playing for the win retreating his
Knight to guard this GN and as we saw in
the game magnus's H Pawn doomed Dennis
for a while was a por up actually maybe
had some small chances but Magnus
finally did pull the break Dennis went
from struggling to maybe even slightly
better with his expertise at handling
that time situation if he can play like
that in the last two games he has a shot
so impressive for such a young
player and that is one of the hardest
things to do in chess is to switch your
mindset when you've been on the defense
for the majority of the game when you've
been trying to hold your defenses and
safeguard your position but then you
realize that an opportunity presents
itself and you can try for more Dennis
seized on it he did not back down
against Magnus gton he tried to win the
position when he had the chance and
that's a Champions mindset and
completely agree with you David if he
can keep this quality up the match is
far from
over so feels like it's just heating up
we've had two games Tanya we're only at
the halfway stage but it feels like
we've seen Dennis level up the first
game difficult but he really stepped up
his game and if he can keep doing that
as young players often do these days
then Magnus
beware yeah Magnus beware and we are up
for a big fight as two more games
remaining what a fantastic game two that
was by Dennis Laz one thing's clear it's
not going to be an easy one he will do
everything to bounce back we'll be back
with more from the chessel
Masters
[Music]
in this video I'm going to show you top
five scholar made attempts in Champions
games before we dive into the games I
would like to show you the pattern if
you have not seen it yet well this
happens when white goes with one E4
black responds with E5 and white plays
Queen to H5 this queen gets into the
game way too fast attacks the pawn on E5
now black plays Knight to C6 guarding
the pawn and white goes with Bishop to
C4 White's two pieces are attacking on
F7 and would like to capture this pawn
and if black is careless and plays
Knight to F6 then we have Queen to F7
and this is a Checkmate Scholars made
attempt to by Hikaru here we have this
game between Hikaru and Philip of anon
and we have one4 E5 Queen goes on H5 and
G6 once again he Carl Queen to F3 once
again gives a try to Checkmate Black's
King black says no I see that and Knight
to E2 we have seen already this kind of
position earlier in the first game so
black plays Bishop to G7 to make sure
that King is castled and here Hikari
goes with D3 black responds with D5
attacks right away in the center white
captures this pawn and black goes with
Knight to B4 the pawn on C2 is hanging
so white has to play Bishop to B3 to
guard this pawn and now we have Knight
to D5 and here we have this end game
where white has very active pieces both
Rooks are controlling the open files and
the bishop is controlling this diagonal
as you can see here those pieces are
concentrated mainly on the queen side
and they are not actually so active and
the king is all the way here on the king
side just alone so why did using this
and plays Rook to E7 gives a check if
King goes on the back rank it will be a
Checkmate uh so black goes to King H6
now and here we have Rook to D6 the pawn
is hanging and it's not just a pawn it's
going to be a Checkmate so King goes
back on G5 plays G6 to guard the pawn
and we have Bishop to C4 attacking The
Rook but what is actually the idea of
this move is that white wants to play
Bishop Bishop to D3 and Checkmate this
King next
move there we go this is the Checkmate
that happened in this game and second
attempt of Scholars made in fact worked
out this game has ended in 39 mes it was
not a Checkmate in for mov but I think
white got really nice play on the king
[Music]
side
oh
the 17-year-old Dennis lasic has done
what few players can do in the world a
difficult end game against Magnus
Carlson holding it we're just second on
the clock Robert what was the most
impressive thing for you about the game
that we just witnessed
all of it from Magnus Carlson pressing
and pressing creating opportunities out
of nowhere to Dennis lazic playing at
98% accuracy the whole way through
despite being in time trouble these two
were very much even in that game and you
could see from the history of it the
trajectory it never left the center
point it was equal the whole way Dennis
LZ deserves a lot of credit for
defending just fantastic fantastic play
by Dennis but he has to keep it going
it's game three Dennis will have the
black pieces if Magnus wins it's match
over and Robert game one was a complete
Magnus Carlson show where do you see
Dennis switching it up are you expecting
a new opening approach by Dennis I think
that Dennis needs to play Sly in this
game with the black pieces I thought
that his opening was absolutely fine but
then things went wrong after the queen
trade so uh for Dennis keep to what you
know and then with the white pieces
maybe then take some risk and I mean
it's hard because because you don't know
what Magnus is going to play in any
single
game David what do you think what are
you expecting from this big game three
coming up because Dennis has to keep
things under control in this one yeah
I'm expecting uh Magnus to minimize the
risk uh Magnus kind of historically he
wants to uh just kind of uh get a
position where he can press but H pull
the break if he needs to for
Dennis it depends on his attitude a lot
of players are happy to just shut up
shop try to make a with black take the
kind of uh take the pressure the
Jeopardy to the final game where Dennis
would have white we know how strong
Dennis is with white after that last
battle but easier said than done you
don't want to be passive you don't want
to play for a draw against Magnus so
actually if Dennis gets the opportunity
especially if Magnus freestyles like he
did in that first game of the day then I
think Dennis should play a bit more
ambitiously in the opening not
necessarily try to trade off Queens like
we saw um in that middle game earlier in
the meantime repeat until this last move
it's the English opening but a different
branch this time the Four Knights and uh
very similar with white F doing the
bishop on G2 but Dennis getting the
black Bishop to a much more
act same but different in this opening
battle Robert and early days but looks
like both players are well prepared well
as you said the bishop on C5 more active
than it was in the previous game uh for
white adopting a pretty similar setup so
Magnus liked what he saw of course he
liked the outcome of that first game
with the win and Tanya I think really
for Dennis the biggest thing is playing
a bit faster it's hard because you're
playing uh the most accurate and
strongest player but you need to
conserve some of that time otherwise
even if you get an even position you may
still collapse so what do you make of
this opening do you like
Dennis's play thus far and do you like
magnus's decision to just slightly
change the move order and the variation
it was so convincing what happened in
game one and that can also be
psychologically difficult for a Dennis
because it's the same opening but it's
different side variation of it a very
similar structure that we see and Dennis
is the one who has to switch it up he
plays magnus's trademark move as David
has told us with that a pawn moving
forward the bishop was attacked the
bishop falls back we're expecting a
trade on E3 but this is interesting
because whoever blinks with this tension
with a dark Square Bishop there are
repercussions on the pawn structure if
white was to take on B6 right now black
ends up with a double Pawn but in return
gets an open C line eventually will push
that a pawn to A4 to undermine the two
pawns B2 A3 which have created a
weakness on the B3 Square meanwhile if
black was to capture on E3 it would have
resulted on a doubled E Pawn how would
you react in this kind of a situation
with this tension do you just keep it on
or do you trade
David it's always a question of whether
you can stand the tension Magnus cannot
heat trades uh I was going to say try
and wait do it on your own terms Force
the opponent to spend their move capture
ing but of course when changes of Pawn
structure are involved um kind of all
bets are off you have to examine the
position for what it is and Magnus he's
got a very specific uh idea here he
wants to go in with the White Queen to
B5 potentially and start attacking some
weaknesses Dennis rubs his eyes there um
I think finally both players are out of
their opening preparation and uh he has
to figure out how to justify he has to
do it energetically but he has to
justify the compromised structure for
black you mentioned Tanya if the black B
Pawn starts moving you're totally fine
uh but for now that isn't possible so
yeah it feels like it's in the balance
evaluation Bar says dead level but a
little bit of pressure at least
psychologically on Dennis uh Bishop to
D5 though very quick idea and uh kind of
ruling out that that Motif I mentioned
Queen to B5 now would end up on a
vulnerable Square once the black Bishop
trades off for the White Knight Black's
Knight actually has a beautiful post in
the middle of the board and highlighted
there Knight to D4 so beware this is is
getting tactical this is getting sharp
no longer the slow strategic struggle
that we've seen actually in the first
two games I've got to say Robert um kind
of similar characteristics in those
first two games but this one could come
to life a bit more yeah now this last
move E3 it takes away the night jump
that you were referencing the Black
Knight wanted to step forward but
whenever you push a pawn you leave a
previously covered Square behind and D3
that's an eyesore in this position
because once the bishop moves out of the
path the D3 Pawn can be captured and
look at Dennis he's not just grabbing a
pawn because he can it wasn't the
computer accurate move I'm going to take
that question mark away if I can I don't
believe that's a question mark I'm just
GNA say you know what the position is
equal you see what I did there equal
position and that is a perfectly good
move protecting your knight preemptively
and by doing so you can now perhaps take
on F3 under more favorable circumstances
because the series of Trades may still
be acceptable for black so it's an even
game Tanya I think that Dennis he has
done everything right thus far but the B
pawns that's the long-term
issue completely agreed and I think that
move by Magnus placing the queen on A4
it's exactly why you want your queen it
it stops the advance of both the a pawn
and the B Pawn from moving forward
trying to create some kind of weaknesses
on the queen side that last move Rook C3
def defends the D3 Pawn that you were
earlier highlighting white is also ey to
get the Rook from F1 double up on the C
line trying to get more control of the O
only open C file that said I think
black's position is also really healthy
yes there's a double Pawn on the B file
but the D3 weakness compensates for
those double
pawns Robert yeah highlighting that pawn
it's a key Square it's all about the
pawn structure here um I think black
needs to keep the Queens on due to the
compromise structure but uh in the
meantime it's white with the first
questions to answer Magnus hesitating
from playing the most natural move in
the position which I would say is Rook F
to C1 activating the white Rook that's
doing nothing sitting at home next to
its king team up double up why not but
something has made Magnus pause and
maybe it's to do with the fact that
there are threats in the position
Black's Bishop can slide back attacking
the White Queen in the near future um
White's D Pawn is week there might be
hits against the White Knight I feel
that that piece is slightly loose right
now and suddenly a lot of calculation to
be done and uh just if we compare this
game the time consumption due to
compared to the previous game mag he
doesn't look happy look on the camera
head in hands the previous game he was
up 6 minutes at this point Dennis was
down at 2 minutes he had eight he was
loving life suddenly tables have turned
uh far less oneway traffic it feels like
Dennis has really gained so much
confidence from that half point from
that earlier draw and uh Magnus
continuing to pause Robert do you smell
danger here what's he thinking about
he's trying to figure out what is his
actual plan yes Rook to C1 that is the
move I would play in bullet chess i'
probably play In classical chess as well
but he's trying to figure out where is
my next plan coming from because let's
say pretty much nothing happens well how
is white going to attack anything I'm
looking at some point to make a move
like D4 as Magnus does double his Rooks
I think that is the Smart play but as
Tanya and you David both were saying
earlier that if black can successfully
Play Bishop C6 and start mobilizing the
B Pawn I don't think that you're too
unhappy about your position so it's a
game of Nuance it's a game of Tempo by
Tempo and for Magnus Carlson he properly
assessed that he can successfully get
his Rooks in line with one another and
wow Dennis gives up the C file are you
shocked by that at all Tanya because he
is playing natural looking moves but now
the open file is whites I'm loving what
Dennis has done and the confidence with
which he's playing this out he trades
one set of Rooks falls back with the
bishop because now there'll never be any
problem of Rook takes Rook on the back
rack the Knight on E7 doesn't need to
keep that Rook defended the bishop and
C6 blocks the open CA line and the point
is it's going to be blacks spawns on the
queen side that are going to start
pushing and try and create weakness one
Pawn one set of Pawns get traded and the
ones that you're drawing arrows on if
white is left with that B2 pawn it
becomes a clear Target and it will not
be the only one the principle of two
weaknesses white already has a weakness
on D3 Dennis trying to create another
one B4 is a threat that Magnus now has
to watch out for and I think the fact
that he paused and took a think Magnus
isn't feeling very comfortable with his
position anymore David not at all Magnus
is on the back foot look at this black
is advancing black has a clearcut plan
we talked about ease of play how natural
it is Dennis he's going to push on the
queen side that's where he's stronger
that's where he has the PO majority
always play on the side uh where you
have more pawns or where you have the uh
the strengths there and um Magnus I
think he's playing to equalize he needs
to try and figure out how to trade off
pieces how to get this game to safety uh
I loved the feature chat a moment ago
where it was saying Dennis he's mastered
the clock he's kind of controlling his
time so much better and uh this featur
chat too Dennis's confidence through the
roof he's now up over a minute on the
clock and Magnus no safety in sight
Robert it feels like at the right moment
I'm not sure now or on the next few
turns he has to play a move like Pawn to
D4 try and trade off everything just uh
try to bail out into a holdable endgame
Magnus because if you get hit by B4 if
was still saddled with that weakness on
D3 Sur things will turn against him do
you think Magnus he's got safety on his
mind I think he should have safety on
his mind and Magnus Carlson he looks at
this position say I would probably
prefer to have this from black because
the ideas are more obvious B4 and trying
to create a two onone situation allowing
yourself to have an outside pass Pawn
later on it's very obvious and for white
D4 doesn't actually carry a next move
threat because of the pins along the
defile and and that's exactly why Magnus
steps his Queen on over to E1 B4 to my
eyes it feels automatic but this E5 Pawn
is also loose you'd prefer to take with
the queen on B4 once the pawn trade
happens but with E5 hanging this
actually becomes quite a difficult
decision I like magnus's last move the
evaluation bar stays where it is maybe
ever so slightly preferable for black
but a complicated struggle so I'm
looking at this really with a fresh set
of eyes and I think that both sides have
their chances Tanya the one great thing
for Dennis his clock he is well ahead on
time doing much better than in the
previous games the kids learn fast and
Robert Dennis realized in the first two
games the amount of pressure on the
board and the amount of pressure on the
clock you can't survive that in every
game he needs to keep the clock under
control which he has and impressively
enough the position as well Dennis right
now definitely has got all these ideas
in his mind he wants to make B4 work but
it's crucial
it's critical that he's able to
recapture that pawn with his Queen to
put pressure on that second weakness
that we were talking about but he goes
for it is he thinking about going Queen
takes Pawn he whoa an inter measle he
wants to capture it with a piece jumps
in with a KN and I see both of you
you're as surprised as I
am brilliant move just the vision the uh
kind of self-control not to
automatically recapture to look for
options and what could be better than a
hit on the opponent's Rook here uh with
a knight and Magnus might have to take
drastic measures we saw Magnus shaking
his head on the camera he goes for it
sacrifices a rook for Bishop and Dennis
raises his eyebrows double exclamation
mark now it's Magnus smiling What's
Happening Here some mind games at work
Magnus knows that he has now been forced
to sacrifice and gamble in a position
where he's a a point up in the match
shaking his head after this Rook is
captured white will take a Pawn on A5
white will have two pawns and a bishop
for a rook level material but so many
open lines you would tend to to think
that a rook would Thrive Robert it's
suddenly got chaotic Magnus what do you
make of his reaction he's just laughing
but I think he's laughing because he
overlooked Black's play and then he felt
fortunate that he had Rook takes C6
because this does muddy the waters
objectively it was the best decision we
saw it given the brilliant move glyph
and it was a brilliant decision but I
think it's because Dennis laic is the
one posing the problems and I love the
way that Dennis continues C5 he is
freezing White's pawns they're not going
to get connected this Knight can in the
near future go to B4 also A6 unavailable
to White because the queen is opened up
along the sixth rank so I do think
Dennis is playing the better game
between these two we see that the
accuracy is about level but the mistakes
that have been made are worse on Magnus
side than whatever mistakes Dennis might
have played thus far so the clock in
Dennis's favor he has a rook to a bishop
in a couple pawns but those pawns are
separated I'm liking Dennis's chances
here and Magnus he has a lot to prove
Pro just incredible stuff he's up on the
clock but let's do a a matte count here
Dennis has an exchange but Magnus has
two pawns Magnus has two pawns on the
bishop for a rook so it's level so far
but exactly the pawn structure that you
were alluding to Robert it creates
weaknesses black can start targeting
these pawns and if Magnus isn't careful
with these pawns they start falling this
is game Dennis then the Knight can jump
to B4 start attacking the D3 Pawn The
Rook can slide over to B8 start
targeting the B2 Pawn the queen can SL
to A6 start targeting targeting the A5
and the D3 Pawn there are lots of
pleasant options for Dennis meanwhile
it's Magnus who needs to be precise I
don't know if I'm overstating this or
not but to me David it feels like so far
Dennis has outplayed Magnus in this game
totally I 100% agree uh the tables have
totally turned since the first game of
today Magnus is way behind on the clock
look at the evaluation bar slipping as
well the the margin for error for Magnus
is Tiny Dennis is just playing Amazing
chess right now and Magnus we see just
below the board uh that game review
Magnus has found one one incredible move
one excellent move double exclamation
mark but that was just to hold the
balance and he's going to have to
continue playing uh brilliantly just to
make a draw here look at Dennis closing
in the blue arrow gave it away that was
Black's best move he's zeroed in he's
going to capture that weak white deepor
we've been talking about for a long long
time maybe even now that pawn could just
be snapped off the board The Black Queen
doesn't necessarily need to capture yet
it would also cost the E Pawn in the
near future but uh Dennis he's the one
making magic happen he's nearly two
minutes up on the clock and Robert I
think this is his opportunity in the
match he needs to strike now this might
be the only chance he gets against
Magnus and for all of our intermedia
players in the audience when you get a
position like this from the white side
and this is what Magnus he's going
through uh these wheels are turning in
his head he wants to figure out what
pieces can be traded ideally he
eliminates all of the queen if he can
eliminate the pawns that I'm going to
put in red he's giving up three white
pawns for two black pawns he feels much
happier about his position because the
pawns are all on one side of the board
so there is an extra Rook compared to a
minor piece and white has two pawns for
that material deficit but as he
envisions the Future Works his way
towards drawish positions not
necessarily A draw that's what he is
aiming for he wants to give up D3 right
now to take E5 he'll give up his B2 and
A5 pawns just to get the C5 pawn and if
he can just liquidate Hoover off all
those pawns then suddenly you feel
better with just pawns on one side of
the
board Queen takes D3 played and now
Magnus the blue arrow again saying that
retreating the bishop is key that's not
obvious that's by far not obvious Knight
takes Pawn is probably the most natural
move right now but there might be some
issues on the back rank watch out the
white king the White Queen they're lined
up if the white if the black queen moves
out the way the black Rook infiltrates
it's just game over so uh already Magnus
living life on the edge Dennis he looks
so confident look at him lean back on
the camera there 17 years old but he
knows he's a real boss already how
obvious do you think that is for Magnus
right now Tanya Bishop to F1 maybe the
only move to survive it's so tough right
it's a retreating move you're not taking
on E5 but of course it's Magnus Carlson
and he of course he finds the best move
but the troubles are far from over black
can also step forward with the queen I
really like the idea that you're
pointing out Queen C2 start not only
hitting and eyeing that B2 Pawn You' got
ideas of Rook jumping onto D1 at some
moment the Knight jumping onto D3 but
Dennis instead chooses to fall back
which apparently turns out to be the
best move I see the evalar doesn't react
says why give up that E5 pawn queen D5
keeping everything under control Robert
you were talking about trades of Pawns
meanwhile Dennis has picked up one pawn
and not given any of his well the same
mental exercise that Magnus was doing
Dennis he understands the same and you
look at this that's why he brought his
Queen to D5 the queen cannot slide into
F3 that is a really difficult move to
play you're giving up your E5 Pawn with
the tempo against the queen on F3 I
don't know how likely this is unless
there is a direct path forward but I
feel like the blue arrow telling us it's
the only move that keeps the advantage
as big as it currently is almost two-
Pawn Advantage for black I think that's
not very likely David how about you I'm
on your team Robert as usual but uh
giving up a pawn it's not Dennis's style
unless he can guarantee he's getting
something back in return Queen to F3
allowing a pawn to drop with a hit on
the black queen I don't think it's going
to happen uh also there are so many
other tempting moves you can push that
pawn to E4 just cement it um I guess you
can move the black Rook you move the
black queen the Knight jumps in instead
also a really nice move he's actually
allowing that ewn to fall but he's
saying okay if you take my knight I will
recapture I'm going to trade off Queens
I'm going to try and simplify down where
my black Rook will beat your black your
white knight so uh Magnus now forced to
push a pawn to B3 but the bar only drops
further and now the idea of Queen to F3
makes much more sense than it did
earlier because you hit F2 you can close
in move in for the kill the white king
is a Sitting Duck I think he might play
that move it looks uh by far more
natural compared to one move ago Tanya
you hit F2 and you hit the D1 Square
white doesn't have the time to take that
Knight on D3 and capture on E5 because
after Bishop takes Knight Rook takes
Bishop Knight takes Pawn Rook to D1
check would be game over so Queen to F3
I love it and if tennis finds this move
Magnus will be in big trouble I want to
hear it from chat and I want to hear it
from you guys given this position both
players under 2 minutes Dennis lovic
plays Queen after what are the chances
of Magnus saving
this uh they don't look good but there
is this outside pass pawn and that is
dangerous there are some loose Pawns in
Black's position and it's not readily
apparent how you deliver the Checkmate
so David I would say that Dennis has
great winning chances I don't know what
number to put it but I'd say more likely
that he wins than Magnus holes and oh
Knight C1 what is
this wow the Black Knight goes on a limb
down onto the white first rank to hit
the White Queen White counterattacks
Magnus now hitting the black queen and
again the blue arrow says that Black's
best move by far is to retreat the black
queen and queen exchange actually white
would potentially be saved but he finds
the best move double attack simply
hitting the White Queen hitting the
White Knight Dennis we were doubting him
but why he's actually threatening some
nasty checkmates as well the black Rooks
coming down to D1 and then taking the
white
Bishop this is just I think it's almost
game over Robert has it just won this on
the spot
it's exactly what I just uncovered that
he is going to Checkmate the white king
the Knight on C1 yes it hits the queen
that looks like it's the job it's doing
it's actually taking away an escape
square a future Escape Square from the
white king So a brilliant set of moves
from Dennis lzic a queen E4 at this
stage yeah that move became much more
natural to his eyes but he just
outplayed Magnus Carlson in this game
and excuse me is that not a free night
isn't Dennis lack about to be up an
entire
Rook uh am mind freaking blown right now
he does a pickup that night it is an
entire Rook it all is down to that a
paon just needs to block this out but
perhaps he can actually even still try
to just go for checkmate you can still
try to double up on that I'm trying to
think of how you can deliver that mate
on H1 is that a possibility but maybe
you have to be a little careful maybe
you're not in time with Rook D1 because
A7 is a threat David how do you parry
this what is the quickest way to wrap
this up because Rook D1 E7 looks scary
it looks scary to allow counterplay
right now and why allow counterplay when
you've done the hard work you have an
extra Rook uh at the very minimum black
can go back the black queen can start
retreating the black Rook still covers
the promotion Square for now but
obviously if you start retreating you
feel like you lose a bit bit of momentum
but Dennis what will he play an obvious
move like Queen to B8 Queen to C7 they
should be fine but uh he still wants to
be accurate look at the nerves on the
camera Dennis he's suddenly scratching
he's uh kind of feeling the tense uh wow
the stakes here Queen to D5 walking into
a light Square diagonal but covering the
promotion Square I like it Robert White
Bishop is stuck in two minds it wants to
kick away this black queen but it will
always open up the white king to checks
if it ever moves so I think he's doing a
good job for now Dennis lazic still some
hurdles to uh uh to get through though
Magnus would love to play Bishop G2 but
it walks into Checkmate so he first
pushes Pawn to A7 now the good news it's
one square away from promotion the bad
news it's easier to team up on and it
can't be defended by a light Square
Bishop so Queen B5 the the plan is clear
for Magnus Queen to B8 check and then he
may tie all of Black's forces down under
17 seconds now for Dennis lazic he's in
huge time TR in fact the engine it's
heading back towards the center Queen d8
an inaccurate Choice here it was a Miss
but this position is really challenging
for him to survive and the F7 Pawn uhoh
that's a big problem oh my God go oh
this is turning he gives up the Black
Knight he offers it as bait to try and
deflect the White Queen double
exclamation mark Queen takes Knight
black will remove that white A7 pawn and
black will win this game brilliant fine
from Dennis lazovic there but Magnus is
still fighting what about the F7 Square
we mentioned T Bishop C4 you don't take
the night you don't give up your key
Pawn e A7 but now there's a double
threat the Knight on B3 is hanging the
pawn on F7 Dennis says you can take a
Pawn on F7 it's only a check my king is
super safe on h8 there are no more
checks to follow and now the C Pawn can
start moving forward is Bishop D5 and
idea but the point is that black will
capture the A7 Pawn eventually capture
that Bishop on D5 so Bishop D5 is not a
resource for white Robert here he's
trying to put pressure but Dennis still
in driver's seat this Pawn needed to be
on e4 the bishop needs to safely hit D5
but as you said The Rook will distract
Queen Magnus himself now he's at 10
seconds he also seeing a pass Pawn run
up the board Bishop G6 it makes a m net
around the black king but look at Dennis
go it's the white king that isn't safe
either and Black's pass Pawn is just as
dangerous as
whites is winning he knows he's winning
it's only the clock that can stop him
now Magnus at one second he moves his
Queen but now a check surely Dennis has
got this in the back he just needs to
get rid of that white Aon and he's going
to do it he's going to win this game
he's going to beat Magnus
Carlson stop him now surely
Dennis is seconds away from what is the
biggest win of his career but watch out
there is a Checkmate in one how do you
fight it do you push the G Pawn do you
slide up with your king he does it he is
fighting it but he still needs to be
careful Magnus is not going to let this
be easy there's so many checks against
that black king there are no Pawns in
front of it and here comes another
mating net the queen can slide back to
H7 at any moment but he's ready to take
this Pawn on E6 Perfect Defense from
Dennis
wow amazing defense look how he's
organized himself The Black Queen now
defending the king the black Rook on a
nice safe Square the Black Knight is
defended as well Magnus swearing Magnus
cursing his luck here he knows Dennis
has done perfectly and he's about to
lose with white Magnus this nearly never
happens the pawn drops Magnus resigns
Dennis takes a historic
Victory Dennis lawick with the biggest
win of his career takes down Magnus
Carlson with the black piece is
unbelievable the 17-year-old has done it
Robert he continues to shine on the
brightest lights and the biggest stages
and he is just Dennis the Menace that's
his nickname a loving nickname from me
because not only did he get here by
beating Hikaru Nakamura Anish giri Maxim
vasher lrav and Jose Martinez he just
scored his first victory in Rapid chess
TI patrols against Magnus Carlson the
highest rated player in chess history we
talk a lot about these teenagers around
the globe often Dennis lasc is
overlooked overlooked certainly no more
he beats Magnus Carlson with black we
have a tied match well who's the
favorite
now oh my gosh I just cannot get over
what we just witnessed I mean that game
from start to finish Dennis always
putting the pressure on winning that
exchange getting that material advantage
winning wining those pawns putting
pressure on magnus's King what a
Flawless play and then defending to
Perfection his own King David that was a
Master Class by Dennis against Magnus
Carlson not something you get to see
every
day that was really really something
special Dennis lazovic that was sick
that was just a brilliant Victory from
him uh I mean just the calmness as well
he won the material he converted it so
smoothly and Magnus was still creating
threats all the checkmating patterns so
easy to go wrong 5 seconds on his clock
every single move having to just trust
his instincts but Dennis lazovic he's
probably the most confident chess player
in the world right now especially after
that Victory and I'm not writing him off
with white he's extra strong uh Magnus
really needs to be uh on Red Alert right
now this next this fourth potentially
final game wow Tanya Robert all bets are
off who could have expected this I'm
gonna say not me for sure especially
after Magnus getting that big first game
win and the style with which he won it I
thought that there's a big chance this
might be match and three to Magnus but
with that comeback in game two saving
that big draw and then the style with
which Dennis just won this one Magnus
Carlson knows this is a fight for his
life this game for Dennis lazovic starts
with the white pieces it's not just the
win but the quality of play by Dennis in
that previous match Robert I just I
don't even know what to say about Dennis
right now I'm just so beyond impressed
by him well one and a half one and a
half is the score it's also very fair
because for the first game and a half it
was all Magnus game one he got the upper
hand early he was able to convert to a
full point in game two he started his
frustrating path forward because Dennis
lvic was a a roadblock he was that
immovable object and for Magus Carlson
you could see like there are nerves on
his face right now because with the
black pieces against someone like Dennis
you can't take unnecessary risk it
doesn't pay off for the most part so
Dennis lvic this is his first time in
the Winner's final he would love to get
to the Grand Final in division one of
the ches Masters the first two and a
half points takes the match we're at one
and a half one and a half tie the next
win it's match
over they're off it's game four and a
Queen's Gambit declined black not taking
on C4 it's the SL defense will we see a
repeat of game two of this Winner's
final no Dennis lavic switches things up
he pushes a pawn where earlier he
brought the White Knight out uh so
Magnus the first to pause um the first
to think we could see still see similar
positions transpositions but Magnus
regaining his composure here Tanya what
do you make of his body
language L and understandably it seems
to have affected Magnus it definitely
did we saw him at the end of game three
Magnus
was angry he was swearing right there he
he couldn't believe what had just
happened we could see that on the camera
and now he's got to come back but the
one thing that's scarier than Magnus is
an angry Magnus and that's what Dennis
has to face right now with the black B
says Magnus going for the slav he goes
for this bishop G4 variation it's not
one that I've played with the black side
Robert break down the plans for us how
do you see this one progressing and is
Magnus just trying to stop the bleeding
and take this to Armageddon Magnus is
taking the solid approach because as we
look at the pawn triangle in the center
black has all of these pawns on light
squares only white has a light Square
Bishop so for Magnus Carlson you
typically prefer to play with the pair
of Bishops as a high level player but
he's saying that I've shut down open
diagonals even Pawn trades won't give it
the full length of the board that it
would like to use to its Advantage so I
think Magnus he just wants to play
quickly he wants to play solidly but
David I mean look at his face he is
still bothered about what's just
happened um understandably as we said
Magnus he's the number one he's the goat
for a reason and he's not used to being
in situations like this where a young
Pretender uh young Rascal comes along
and uh kind of knocks him and kind of
threatens to kick him off his perch but
um yeah he needs to recover Magnus and I
think he's doing the right thing I like
Black's opening Choice here I like the
fact that Magnus is gone for this really
renowned solid variation because
ultimately Dennis doesn't want to take
too much risks either yes he's riding a
high yes he just beat Magnus but it's
not his style Dennis to kind of uh kind
of set the pace to be the one pushing
and pushing and kind of taking risks so
Magnus he's saying okay if you want to
win come at me uh I'm happy to just
recover and uh as you mentioned Robert
Rock Solid from black the pawn formation
the skeleton of Black's position no real
issues here yet at least um does have a
reputation I've played this myself of
being slightly passive for black again
white has the bishop pair of factor we
talk about longterm but uh ultimately
yeah this game I think it could have
gone worse for Magnus if he'd uh kind of
been too emotional and wanted to strike
back immediately so he's just trying to
uh now with this trade of Pawns break
open the center I'm expecting Pawn to E5
now and he's trying to neutralize Dennis
try and get out of this game and I don't
think either of us would complain right
Tanya if we saw
nagon absolutely I think uh if this
match goes down to the V if any match
deserve to go down to the V it is this
one and it's going to be a spicy
Armageddon speaking about who wants to
push well Dennis isn't going to be a
push over in the Armageddon he's taken
down Anish G he's taken down Maxim VRA
in the chessable Masters in the
Armageddon he's going to be taking a lot
of confidence from that the E5 break
that you were alluding to in the current
position I think that's definitely on
magnus's radar he's just preparing it a
little bit first falls back with that
Bishop white can start pushing his own
Central pawns try to take uh that space
with E4 which I think will be met by
your move E5
David on the board and uh at least E4 is
with a big big threat white wants to
play E5 so surely black has to stop it
here um that would be a for a double
attack if white steps forward one more
square and there we go Magnus does
indeed block and uh now okay Dennis
advances locking the center sometimes
not favorable if you have the bishop
pair but here it's all about control of
the light squares Magnus doesn't want to
allow white to sit with a protected pass
Pawn forever but if he ever trades on
the D5 Square White's light Square
Bishop will gain in power Robert I like
Dennis's last couple of moves he's
showing ambition here it looks nice for
white this bishop on C4 is a much better
piece than it was a few turns ago
because that pawn triangle all in light
squares blocking its diagonals that's no
more and it will open up towards the
black king at some point but look at
Magnus he says all right I concede that
your Bishop will be strong but how about
my Bishop on C5 how about some of the
control that my Knights will get this
Knight can wrap around to B6 at some
moment so both players they need to
figure out what the optimal squares are
for their pieces and it's actually not
that easy one big decision is should
white take on C6 to isolate both of
Black's queenside pawns but isolated
pawns open files an open B file could be
useful for black and that's why Dennis
he keeps the status quo and he maintains
a slight
pull I think this one is very likely
heading to that Armageddon that we're
looking at with that last trade and a
queen trade being offered to Magnus
you've been talking about body language
looking at him uh David I think this
game for him is about calming down and
just knowing that you know with the
black pieces doesn't want to lose
control of anything and we take this uh
fight there but now the big question is
do you trade Queens especially against
mag
here normally I would say no don't do it
against the best endgame player of all
time the endgame Maestro himself but
here you do gain a bit of time
potentially he drops back though Dennis
lavic H fearing those words maybe
echoing in his ears don't trade Queens
against Magnus but uh now at least the
structure changes and um Dennis I was
going to say is he going to take back
with a pawn maybe the most ambitious
move but be settled with an isolated
porn of his own uh or does he play it
safe does he take back on this square
with a piece the bishop the Knight um
sport for Choice here and at least on
the camera visibly Magnus seems to have
calmed down Robert what do you make okay
of this Knight capture from
Dennis I thought we might get this
continuation because the risk associated
with isolating your own Pawn sure you
would have had a pass Pawn I don't think
that's Dennis's style I don't think he
wanted any part of that and this looks
very level and this move Queen back to
E7 it's so that when or if black takes
on D5 and and The Rook takes back the
queen isn't hit so it's a bit of a
prophylactic move it's a defensive move
and I actually think that if Dennis
isn't careful Knights can outclass
bishops because this bishop is on its
optimal square but later down the line
if you can Envision a knight somewhere
out on a important dark Square maybe F4
maybe D4 it's a long ways away so I
don't think it's going to happen but
Knights can be very jumpy tricky pieces
so Dennis just can't assume it's going
to be a draw Magnus he typically plays
on if there's any life left
Magus doesn't look too Lively right now
though too energetic um I think if he
wants to get this game towards safety
there we go he'll happily trade off all
the Rooks and uh Robert that Dynamic you
mentioned queen of Knight versus queen
and Bishop yeah maybe some chances long
term so Dennis shouldn't relax too early
never relax against the top players of
course but ultimately Tanya I think your
prediction draw and Armageddon looks by
far the most likely outcome right now
and you mentioned Queen and Knight
versus queen and Bishop it gives chances
to the side with the Knight cuz they can
get tricky but if even the Queens come
off if it's just a pure Bishop versus
knight end game with pawns on both
flanks it's actually white with the
bishop a longrange piece that can start
pushing a little bit the king can come
out the bishop can be on D5 controlling
more of the board so it's really about
who manages to get the ideal trades in
uh but I think both players are making
quick moves quick improving moves and we
are going to see either the Queens come
off or the Rooks come off but I highly
doubt that this will head to a pure
Bishop versus knight because in that
case Dennis will be the one who will be
pushing yeah that would not be good to
get Bishop versus knight I think that
with a knight where it currently sits it
covers many key squares and don't be
surprised when Magnus throws his H Pawn
forward right now is one option he can
also play on The Queen side I just feel
like some of Black's moves are a little
bit easier to play than whites this open
D file it looks just as strong as the
open C file but I don't know something
about this position is making it
difficult for me to see what White's
actual plan is David do you see anything
for either side honestly and how you can
play for more than just
equality it's tough I think ultimately
the position is equal I would have said
actually until this last move that
Magnus is going to play his trademarks
he's going to play H5 just to tickle
pretend that he's pushing some pawns
forward on that flank uh towards the
white king then he might play A5 pretend
he'll push the B Pawn as well on the
other flank but I think magnus's mood is
uh different right now than it was
earlier in the day he's just happy to
guide this game towards safety and um
yeah Rook to D4 might be the only way to
imbalance things you pointed it out
there Robert on the on the board Rook D4
would have changed the pawn structure
potentially but uh now that the Rooks
are off it looks too symmetrical look at
the pawn structure pretty much almost
symmetrical should still be a draw but
queen of Knight we
mentioned would choose black slightly if
I had to uh I wanted to ask the question
though assuming that this one stays
level who do you think is the happier
player and who do you think wants black
in the
armagedon wow that's uh that's a tough
one but I think it's a really important
question David because I think both
players will try and get the result odds
they will try to get the black pieces
but then how low can you actually go to
attain that I don't know who's going to
win the Armageddon bid but I am
predicting a a bid around 6 and 1 half
minutes by these players what about you
it I think that Dennis yeah he has shown
a willingness to get low on the clock he
also just brought his King out into the
open you you can use your kings as
weapons in the end game everybody
although now black is aiming at a pawn
But to answer the Armageddon question I
think that Magnus he's willing to go
quite low he's been way faster in this
match thus far for
Dennis yeah I feel like seven minutes is
probably the lower limit just because he
constantly finds himself in time trouble
and he won't won't have increment to
rely on so I feel like Dennis will
probably end up with the white
pieces guys you got answer your question
too we're not going to let you off the
hook so easily I was about to deflect
and uh try to dodge that one um but I
agree I think uh both players will be
quite Keen especially Magnus now after
this last game to get the black pieces
Magnus lost with white so why not try to
get black um I also wanted to point out
the accuracy this game I mean it's such
a high class game and sometimes
ultimately a drawers logical result in
chess 98% accuracy for both players um
yeah I think Magnus would love black and
he might go lower than we expect I think
he'll be super Keen to get the uh draw
odds but right now a pause for Magnus a
bit of a frown on the camera do you
think he'll try and uh grind this one we
keep saying tickle Dennis here creates
some threats Pawn to H5 we predicted
actually both the Rooks pawns starting
to march here
Robert typical Magnus and he may even
throw that pawn one step further because
if white responds with G4 this may be
hard to visualize for some you're just
giving black all of the dark squares so
when your opponent has a knight and you
have a light Square Bishop how can you
control dark squares if your pawns are
on dark squares since they capture
diagonally so you have to be very
careful here if you're Dennis laic I
know that the bar is in the middle the
draw seems to be the likely result but I
we've seen it from Magnus countless
times in his illustrious career you take
one move off and suddenly you're in
trouble so it does white stop that but
give black this very important G4 Square
looks a bit worrisome to my eyes do you
allow black to play H4 and then harm
White's Pawn structure also looks
problematic I do think that Dennis has
to invest some serious time here and
he's already down almost three minutes
on the clock why should Magnus just make
a draw and actually his latest move
allows black to play H4 this is
risk-free chess from the number one
player and on your point Robert Pawn to
H4 if it's ever captured uh Magnus will
smile he'll love that he'll happily
throw a porn away White's porn structure
will be totally ruined with Queens on
the board you cannot allow that the
black queen will happily at some point
sneak over towards the king side the
Black Knight will have access to some
Outpost so a lot of viewers at home
might be wondering why Pawn to H4 for
black it's a pawn sacrifice you're
giving it away but h no you're breaking
the opponent's structure and wow I'm
really surprised Magnus didn't go for it
but oh okay no I'm showing I'm showing
what's happening if this game he did not
go for this maybe he's going to go for
it later but I just wanted to highlight
that F4 and the dark Square so B5 was
pled no I guess David you are correct he
didn't go for it but is it going
anywhere I guess is the question Tanya I
want to just highlight the idea behind
this last move B5 I think after H4
Dennis intended to play Queen to C4
which is why he made this retreating
move Bishop to B3 we've been talking
about the different trades in the
position that how a queen trade would
actually favor white so B5 was a really
nice prophylactic move by Magnus taking
away a key Square which would have
forced to trade because it's not only
offering that Queen exchange but also
that F7 weakness uh which is why Magnus
did not rush with H4 played B5
controlling the square and now Dennis is
offering a bishop trade on D5 and I
think if Magnus picks this up are you
going to uh go into a King Pawn ending
will you calculate that well none of
that neither of the players want it
Magnus steps back attacking the H3 Pawn
the king comes back and we're expecting
that move h for to land about
now especially if Magnus wants to win
this game or if he wants to keep any
winning chances alive but feels like
hesitation here Robert indecision from
the world number one Magnus just drops
his King back doesn't necessarily
improve things he's coming towards the
center hinting he might take the white
Bishop but still yet to go for that H4
um why do you think he's waiting why
isn't he pulling the trigger and going
for it well thank you for the hint
because I was thinking that Knight takes
D5 made White's life easy but you're
absolutely correct that especially if
the Queens come off there the black king
can Dart to the center and black may
just win the pawn where it lands on D5
so white needs to be very careful I'm
not so sure about some of these
decisions from both players frankly but
the pawn on B4 is it a weakness is it a
strength you do get a Pawn on a dark
Square your Bishop can't help defend
that later on but that also freezes
Black's Pawn on a light Square so your
Bishop can go after that this is a
Magnus
will he push will he press T it does
feel like his style of endgame here but
is there enough life left and that's the
big question is there enough life left
are there enough pieces left and to my
eyes it just feels like you don't have
enough resources to make that much of it
but that said with this bishop on D5
still underpin with this bishop on D5
always this trade being offered I think
this is the best position that Magnus
has had all game and it just comes down
to how I'm ambitious will he feel but
does he want to play this out till the
very end does he want to go into an
Armageddon or is Dennis savic getting
ambitious F4 was not a move on my
radar Robert I see the expression on
your face I think it matches mine I mean
this feels desperate F4 looks ambitious
but it's also going to weaken the white
king the white porn structure is never
going to be intact anymore huge huge
gamble there from Dennis lazic with two
minutes left and I think for Dennis he
was tired of sitting and waiting feeling
like Magnus was getting the upper hand
slowly but surely but F4 here and even
if you swap Pawns in this square that
now the dark squares are really
vulnerable in a move like Queen C7 maybe
you could start with Queen C7 in some of
these positions as well because the
white king is exposed also on the second
rank so I don't know about that decision
the EV uh engine the evaluation bar it
says that it was incorrect but maybe it
will pay off because it does muddy the
water so it's not just one-sided in mag
favorite idea on the board I like the
fact that Dennis pre moved G takes F4
because every second counts at this
point down to two minutes and queen to
C7 hitting that pawn just hinting at
coming in and behind that's the most
uncomfortable thing in chess when an
opponent's Queen is down kind of in your
grill down on the first second ranks and
uh I mean pretty much Unstoppable the
black queen is coming in One Direction
or the other yes white can go and take
the B5 Pawn but you might just get
checkmated along the way so um you have
to be really careful now this is where
Queen and Knight if they get to attack
together will be so dangerous right
Tanya White's Bishop might not be able
to participate in the defense on the DW
yeah some really big committal decisions
taken by Denis the last couple of moves
and I think what he's calculating right
now is can he Force matters can he go E5
forcing the trade on D3 but you have to
be really careful for sorry forcing the
trades on D5 you have to be super
careful because that allows Black's
Queen to infiltrate you might lose the
A3 Pawn with checks and then are you in
time to give perpetuals he doesn't go
for it he falls back with the queen
defending that F4 Pawn Robert you don't
like this move well the blue arrow tells
the full story here Queen D6 freezes
white the queen went to the pawn F4 is
defense now Queen on D6 threatens Knight
takes E4 because the bishop on D5 is
pinned and in certain end games you can
even just take this bishop on D5 King E7
it was a miss this deserves the X
sometimes I throw that X out the window
and say no that's a perfectly fine move
Queen D6 not easy to play because using
a pin but walking into a potential forks
and things of that nature are not easy
but I do feel like Dennis is in trouble
here I don't really care what the engine
says it's the position of the white king
it's that the white pieces feel a bit
clumsy he needs to do something fast
otherwise he's just going to lose he's
also down now to just 53 52
seconds we saw the first clue as well
that Dennis is getting nervous on the on
the camera uh I'm just watching him
there there was a slight almost
imperceptible Shake of the head suddenly
scratching his head as well he's
realizing all there's no natural moves
in 40 seconds left again the clock is
ticking Magnus asserting the upper hand
yet again on the clock and Tanya you
mentioned it when you're low on time
it's natural you want to force the issue
and he's going for it now he's trying to
force the trade of Knight for Bishop
what do you think uh is this going to
save Dennis well the evalar helps us
turns out that it is a right moment and
the right decision the big question to
me at that moment was that if black was
to capture on D5 give checks with the
queen when black wins that A3 Pawn that
Side Pawn that white has can Black's
King be under danger are there enough
checks is there a Perpetual but I think
with magnus's King now placed on E7
these lines work out for Dennis he's
just going to capture the D5 Pawn Magnus
if he comes in with the queen starts
getting greedy I think there's a
Perpetual against the E7 King here
there's just one thing that Dennis needs
to be alert about if he brings his King
to the third rank there could be a
sneaky check on B3 trying to create a
pass Pawn so Dennis he has a drawing
mechanism of his own the black king is
in actually in a bad position because
once the black queen leaves Queen D6 to
B8 and back to D6 you put it on a yo-yo
string it's going to deliver a draw but
Magnus he poses a really challenging
question to Dennis now can you trade
Queens because that could be a losing
King and Pawn in game and Dennis has 30
seconds to figure it out
wow what a tough decision now Dennis he
has to risk either he has to trust
Magnus and Dodge the queen trade or he
has to risk a king and por end game
Queen to C5 check instead I think a wise
decision if in doubt take the safer
option King and porn end games are pure
calculation it's move by move you're
either winning or losing or drawing like
nothing in between you can't just wing
it so Queen to C5 check now the black
king uh Tanya you mentioned it's not
entirely safe do you think it's going to
step forward is Magnus going to be
feeling brave wow there done he answers
the question for me and a mistake by
Dennis he moves his own King forward but
this gives Magnus the time to actually
infiltrate with his Queen and now I
think the point is that he can go Pawn
hunting because Black's King is going to
March up the light squares and be safe
and there might not be a Perpetual then
that's exactly what's happening here but
the players they don't have any blue
arrows they don't have an evaluation bar
to the side telling them that this is
the moment but for Dennis lack he's been
Hanging On by a thread for the last
bunch of moves here Queen D3 check and
as you said Tanya the King by thread and
needle can use those light squares and
it is going to be a problem for White
and the King G3 what a natural move to
play to avoid any kind of queen trade
Queen D5 was gonna offer Queen trade
with Black's King in a favorable spot
David will Magnus find Queen D3 first
and King F5 second yes because Robert I
want to point out don't play King F5 now
if you play King F5 enter with the black
king you lose on the spot the white Pawn
will step forward to E6 with a
discovered check and you have to retreat
with the King taking this Pawn you get m
in the center of the board so process of
elimination you cannot Advance your king
first you have to go for a check and
only then once your queen is safe drive
forward with your own King it's a race
between Kings right now and uh Magnus we
think he's going to go for it do you see
the blue arrow here G5 check I assume if
Pawn takes there might be Queen C4 is
that one of those ideas that you can
play to force the Queens off the board
and get a pass Pawn that is incredibly
deep and it goes to show that pawn
quality it often outpaces Pawn quantity
and especially end game like this G5
check is played I'm GNA freak out
because that just looks impossible there
are no Protectors of that square and
white has two pieces covering it we're
all going to fall out of our chairs if
G5 check is played but Magnus has 25
seconds always look for check first
that's the moral of the story either
they're very good or you rule them out
and you look for something uh better but
okay he's really going low on the clock
he plays the more natural move King to
F5 missed opportunity maybe winning
there some checkmates or queen trades
and now wow blue arrow says the best
move to keep the balance the only move
is to give away the pawn and Dennis has
done it he's going for Perpetual check
can the black king escape from the white
Queen's gaze right now o no more check
suddenly why does he sacrifice the pawn
why is this genius because the King
march now it's is being brave and
adventurous with the white
king yeah I I didn't see another check
and I was really surprised but like you
said the black queen needs to defend all
these checks and he goes Pawn hunting
but now there's got to be a Perpetual
now you start just checking the king and
you don't allow Black's Queen you
probably give a check from C5 making
sure that the black queen cannot come to
defense he does exctly
that we're going to be careful Dennis
the black queen can swoop back to block
some of these ch as she just does there
and Dennis did he miss that one he lent
back in his chair 2 seconds he's playing
purely on the increment now shaking his
head the black king is going to slide
away slink away to safety and the white
king might get checkmated be careful
here a queen trade what an offer and
it's a draw so it was brilliant by
Dennis Laz apparently this is a hold but
not after that move he had to play B5 a
moment ago now it's too
slow start a race Dennis laic he had no
time to calculate shaking his head now
the black porns are going to March
forward to Victory heartbreak he was one
accurate move away so close but Magnus
is going to do it endgame magic
again we
go he does it he gets the win in and
that was an insane insane finish what
just happened there David we saw the bar
go up and down it's a heartbreaking
moment but Dennis lazovic was so close
to getting the job done to take it to
Armageddon
so close but not close enough as Magnus
Carson works that end game magic pure
Instinct there from both players at the
end no time on the clock but uh it was
Dennis who made the final mistake in a
complicated Queen end game we can
forgive him it was a difficult difficult
position but he ultimately did let it
slip right to the death after great
defense but Magnus as always seems to
emerge victorious in these end games
what an amazing end game that was and
for Dennis lazic you know he took to
Magnus he pushed his pawns it was
inaccurate at first but then he jettison
the pawn brought his King forward and
even offered a queen trade that while
black had some winning plans once the
queens were traded it objectively was
the right decision so his intuition is
unreal he's just 17 years old he'll
continue to sharpen his play his
openings his Pace but he was really
every bit of Magnus Carlson's equal
until those final few moves when Magnus
was able to escape with Victory and thus
the
match hold it in his own in game two
bouncing back in game three getting that
win in taking it to game four Janis
lazic kept it so under control in that
one as well and we saw the bar go all
crazy it was a yo-yo position and maybe
David at some point you can just go
through those last couple of moves CU
there was so much action that happened
but in the end Magnus Carlson's endgame
technique proail Magnus Carlson goes
into the grand final of the chessable
Masters he knocks that Dennis lavic who
will have one more life who will be
waiting in the losers final to play the
winner of yan naami and Ali Rea fuja
David that was one of the craziest ends
that we've just witnessed there a
moments when it looked like Dennis had
it then moments when it looked like
Magnus has it what happened there it was
Topsy Turvy a roller coaster this is why
we always say study your end games
practice your end games Queen end games
though are the trickiest of the bunch
and I did want to show the moment where
it all turned it actually turned
multiple times in the space of a few
seconds in the space of just one or two
moves as Dennis went from a drawn
position to a losing position back to a
draw and then ultimately let it slip and
um if we can show that on the board um
yeah Dennis just with no time left he
made a very human error and uh really
unfortunate there but uh Magnus
ultimately he pounced on the opportunity
and uh he's just so ruthless when he
gets even the smallest of chances uh so
it was here that things started to go
wrong for Dennis lazovic the most
difficult move I would say to keep the
balance King into H6 finding safety
Behind Enemy Lines really not obvious at
all instead he played the move Queen to
E5 given a question mark and it was a
mistake but it was a gamble that could
well have paid off Magnus missed the
winning move Pawn to F6 check this would
have been simply incredible we would
have seen a race after the Queen's
disappear Magnus pushing the H Pawn for
Glory now but the white B Pawn most
importantly can be stopped by the black
king the black king is within this box
stops the white pawn and the black pawn
Queens first Magnus missed this with no
time on his clock traded queens and
suddenly it's back to a draw after King
to E7 Dennis could have initiated a race
that he would have emerged well from uh
he would have kept the balance with Pawn
to B5 when the black king moves away the
white king comes in and the white E Pawn
runs forward but he took his foot off
the pedal just for one move instead
retreating King to F4 but losing time in
temp and Tempe in end games is fatal
King to F4 allowed the black king to
step forward and the black pawns to
start rolling it was a matter of time
then and Magnus converted ups and downs
twists and turns but uh as usual it is
that man again Magnus
gson beautifully explained there David
just how rich and complex this end game
was and how difficult this end game was
and in the end Magnus Carlson did
Prevail he gets the win he gets the job
done Dennis lawick in the elimination
bracket and don't go anywhere cuz we
will be back with Magnus Carlson joining
us for an interview see you in just a
[Music]
few
this is John John John loves to study
chess this is David David loves to study
chess as well but
efficiently John spends more time
setting up the board and figuring out
what's on the page of his book than he
gets to
study David likes to take it easy and
use his time
[Music]
wisely David is finished exercise for
today John should try the
[Music]
same I'm here with Magnus Carlson world
number one and to many greatest chess
player of all time we're going to ask
him a few questions I'm going to name a
sport you have to tell me the greatest
of all time mhm sounds good yeah
basketball LeBron
James soccer Messi I agree with both
baseball Barry
Bonds what did he say Okay football like
American
football Tom Brady I guess okay yeah
good one uh tennis jovic
golf
tiger Fair poker do
Brunson that's a unique one
chess gar Kasparov are you allowed to
say yourself
I don't know if I'm allowed but I think
Gary is the best of all time still chess
boxing I'm on Hamilton I agree we're
going to play this or that would you
rather go on a cruise or road trip road
trip comedy or thriller comedy coffee or
tea tea but only slightly preferably
neither how do you get energized the
sun cats or dogs cats but I like dogs
too it's like a this or that is a little
bit tough with you you like everything
shower or bath oh shower for sure okay I
don't have the patience to take baths
are you a morning person or a night owl
Night Owl for sure would you rather get
on a phone call or text message text
prob I feel like the answer for you is
neither feel like it's just usually
yes just go sunrise or sunset sunrise
winter or summer summer how many beers
would would it take for you to drink for
me to beat you in a classical chess game
that's a very difficult question uh cuz
I'd probably sober up during the game so
I'd probably have to keep drinking
probably start with 20 and take it from
there 20 okay how what's the size of the
cup um pints wow okay 20 name your price
if you have to chess box um $10 million
do you prefer to play chess on a
computer over the board or on your phone
I rarely play on my phone I I would say
I prefer to play on the computer in your
entire career have you ever had a day
where you went I think this guy might be
as good as me in
chess
no uh well I mean not not not you know
since not the last 10 years for sure
okay has it ever
been this guy might be kind of close to
me if I have a bad day yeah uh I would
say Fabia to his best was um very close
in In classical for sure my other
question was going to be who do you
think is the second best chess player in
the world so I suppose yeah I think
Fabian corana is the is the second
second best player thank you Magnus for
sitting down with us and doing these
rapid fire questions now get out of
here
yeah
and we're back we're being joined by the
three times reigning tour Champion world
number one Magnus Carson Magnus
congratulations uh on that win it was a
fantastic match to watch a big fight
take us through the match uh what did
you make of it and how was
it um yeah obviously it became very
difficult after
uh after game uh three
um I I
mean the honestly like the for most of
game three and and uh also game four I
was just pretty tilted by the way the
matches was going but
um you know I think both in in game one
and uh in game four like he's like he's
a kind of player always thinks for very
long and like sometimes he plays well
under time pressure but I don't think
you can rely on playing well in those
situations all the time so a couple of
times he he was show on time and he
eventually cck it
was not
[Music]
easy Magnus game one you won it so
convincingly and we were also impressed
watching that and then game two you put
so much pressure but then there was the
this great resistance from him was that
frustrating in game two to just see him
hold on with that
draw well I mean he also had an
opportunity which I realized right after
I made the move like I blundered my H
Pawn due to a fork which is like doubly
silly cuz that fork was there on the
board a few mons ago so he actually had
a chance to take over there as well uh
but yeah apart from that um he did
really well I wouldn't expect I wouldn't
say that I ever like expected
to
um uh to to win uh but I I you know I
certainly
um uh was certainly hoping so um and
yeah um I I think I think so he made a
positional Mistake by trading on C6 and
then going Queen D4 it looks like he
Saddles me with um a weak Pawn on on C6
and a bad Bishop but the reality is is a
bit um different since I can just
maneuver the Knight around my king will
find a beautiful Square on D6 and so on
but yeah for sure after that he did did
well and after that the match was was
just a mess
[Music]
and um you know with some luck you could
have uh could have won
what happened in game
three uh I just you know I started to
play a bit indifferently he did really
well for a while um finding a lot of lot
of very good moves uh and I'll say
like
um I'd sort of I'd seen from afar that
he could play this Knight D5 move after
A4 but then I forgot about it and I
realized like immediately as I
played um the move A4 so that oh 95 is
happening so then the exchange sa was
more tilt than
anything anything
else um and uh yeah after that I mean I
thought that was coming back in the game
with my Aon but then I couldn't find
anything and um I think he did did well
um um but yeah that was
pretty pretty tting but it got to give
him got to give him credit for um for
finding a lot of um a lot of big Mose in
that
game yeah it was very impressive to
watch and we saw you react at the end of
game three did you feel like you missed
some chance at the end there were you
just what happened there no it was just
frustrating um I didn't feel that i'
missed any particular chance I just
thought I was close to coming back and I
couldn't find it and it was such an
unnecessary loss in in general so that
was just annoying me that because I I
felt I felt after I'd won the first game
like he's usually very solid but unless
like you give him chances it doesn't
create create them that easily which is
which is you know perfectly normal at
17 um with the classical rating the
house is not supposed to uh be uh be
creating a lot of chances against the
against the best players but um so yeah
that was just felt so unnecessary to let
him back into the match that way um
and yeah of course the fourth game as I
said I was pretty tilted when I started
I play I play this line that I usually
play only when I'm tilted I just give
away the bishop pair try and play solid
not to think too
much and I mean fortunately I managed to
even though I was a bit wor I managed to
equalize after that and there was
nothing special going on and after that
you know I can start
using technique which pretty much
regardless of the state of mind I can do
can do okay H was there a moment that
you think that this is going to go into
uh an
armagedon yeah I wasn't worried about
Armageddon particularly um I was just
trying to play and and see but I mean I
I
certainly missed
opportunities and he could have taken it
into the armor get him but I wouldn't
say I was thinking too much about it or
worried about
it Magus we've been so amazed with
Dennis's run in this entire chessable
Masters and also the resistance he put
against you today U with this experience
of playing against him what do you think
it is about his style and his play that
that lets him survive these formats
against the very best in the
world he's just fundamentally very
[Music]
sound it's good
understanding um so he's yeah he's not
easy to to break down and think with
some some experience he's going to
become a top top
player yeah have you been impressed with
how he plays with such little time on
the
clock yeah
um as I said like he plays rather slowly
so he gets into a lot of time trouble
and I mean I wouldn't recommend that
necessarily as a sustainable approach
especially with two second
increment but it's certainly a sign of
um of huge talent that he can he can
keep it going at least sometimes even
though in those
situations and Magna such a match an up
and down match is that also
psychologically mentally
exhausting no it's just
annoying all right fa I'm going to put
in some final chat questions to you
before we let you go and uh
yeah just a couple more minutes uh the
first one is by I'm going to butcher
this name it's K guard and he wants to
know how do you mentally reset for a new
game after what happened in game
three I don't I was just tilted when I
started you know we didn't have any time
in between the games really either so I
was still tilted but you know it's a new
game to
play but no I didn't feel
you still made it work for yourself uh
the next question is by wear 15 and he
says what do you think about this new
format this season Magnus it's 10
minutes with a 2cond increment very
different from uh last season we've been
having some chaotic end games which are
fun for fans maybe not so much for the
players how does this different time
control change the
Dynamics yeah I think that's summed it
up pretty well it's definitely stressful
for
for the players
um and um I think a lot of players are
struggling with it a bit to find um the
Rhythm so I think it's um he sums it up
pretty well but you know as long as it's
good for for the fans that's um that's
um obviously very important which one do
you prefer 15 plus 3 or the 10 plus
two
I like this I like this format it makes
it you know anything that can make a day
of work a little bit
shorter it's good not to say that that I
don't don't um don't enjoy and enjoy uh
these tournaments is
just um you know means you have more
time to do other things that's
all all right and uh one more question
for you from the chat what is Magnus
looking forward to in
2024 uh I'm looking forward to a lot of
things but uh in the near future I'm
looking forward to um to the final uh
that's going to be on Wednesday I
suppose and I'm very much looking
forward to playing um freestyle chess um
classical uh St a few days after that's
something I wanted for for a long time
and that's going to be the first time
that we'll have Fisher random In
classical
format it it is uh and
um you know playing these games now
rapid
chess um with kind of normal chess and
then uh and then fish random chest uh
fish random classical later I mean
that's pretty much what I what I want so
in in that sense you know this is a good
week is Fisher random becoming your
favorite format or one of your favorite
formats I
wouldn't it's it's hard to say though
cuz I really like Blitz and Rapid with
normal chest still especially
lits so a bit a mix of a mix of several
things is
nice all right variety and finally
Before I Let You Go Magnus Grant final
coming up who are you expecting to fight
uh in that is there a player do you have
a preference who you'd want to meet in
the Grand
Final
um I
think uh see probably ala is a slight
favorite against
Yan um and
then
yeah this the other match is fairly
fairly open I would say guess ala is
would maybe be my bet at this moment to
go through but then again he has to
win two
matches it's very hard to say so you
think ala is the favorite and is he the
opponent that you'd like to play in the
Grand Final he was an opponent you
wanted in the world championship Once
Upon a
Time yeah love playing ala he always um
puts a lot of pressure he plays very
ambitiously so I'd love to to play him
but you know it's a privilege to be in
the final regardless so from I'm play
whomever I play
I'm yeah I think this is your fifth out
of six Champions chest St finals uh
counting last season as well so you've
made a habit out of it uh Magnus I know
David joked about you having a rest day
today but you've got two rest days
before the Grand Final that's quite a
bit of time how do you plan to spend
it um I plan to travel to Germany and
then uh you know enjoy my last day in in
Spain
tomorrow all right you don't get one but
you get two rest days enjoy get some
rest Magnus we'll see you in the Grand
Final thank
you
bye Magnus Carlson there after his win
against Dennis lack makes it to Grand
Final gets to 2 days off will be flying
to Germany we'll see him back meanwhile
we will have big action in the losers
bracket as Yan Nai fights alira fuja in
the loser semi-finals the winner will
play against Dennis lawick a big fight
coming up Robert David Magnus picked Ali
Rea as a slight favorite to take uh this
to the Grand Final what's your take on
this well I think by the odds Dennis
lavic he might be the odds onfair
because he gets a buy he awaits the
winner of Ali Rea fua versus Yan naami
but as Magnus said Ali Rea he always
brings the fight he's such a fun player
to face off against but you who knows in
this field yand pomi super tough finding
some Rhythm there too I don't know who
is GNA make it through but I do know
that Magnus Carlson even when he's not
his happiest he's still playing baller
chess yeah Magnus uh he made it through
that's what the top sports players the
top sports teams do even even when
they're not that they best they grind
out the result they find a way to get
the job done and uh I think he was
trying to dodge the topic there he
doesn't want a rematch against Dennis
lazic because today was so tough but
nice to see Magnus relieved and uh in a
good mood after that
Victory and that was such a big fight
and I think the players also enjoy when
there's a big fight on the board and you
win a match like this uh and then David
as he said he gets two days off he
wanted today off now he gets two days to
enjoy himself but he's got a Grand Final
to look forward to as well uh and let's
bring up after this day of the chasel Ms
and what a day it's been let's bring up
our uh chessable Masters standing
presented by the wealth management
partners of the Champions chess Julius
bear and here we have it it is Vladimir
fedos Jose Martinez who got eliminated
today they go back home while fed
Martinez Maxim VRA Wesley so it's the
end of the road for them the action
continues uh and a big paycheck as well
for all of them and I'm sure Robert
we're going to see some of these names
back on the door we certainly will
Wesley so did not have his best showing
in division one but he made it to the
finals of the Champions chess Tour live
event in Toronto so between Wesley Maxim
Jose and Vladimir fedos of the season
has just begun it's not easy to make it
back here in fact some of the biggest
names in chess are not individ one it
goes to show that there's no guarantees
not in the Champions chess tour 2024
yeah we saw those four spots still there
in those standings presented by Julius
barar and players don't want to fill in
those spots too quickly they want to get
into the Grand Final and before we say
goodbye to Chad before we sign off David
your final thoughts about the action
that we witnessed
today oh so much action I love that
seesaw match between Nishi and fed of
earlier I just love the fight in Dennis
lavic we're seeing a superstar just
evolving and growing before our very
eyes but ultimately it was Magnus
Carlson who took over um just a great
day of Chess and really shaping up
nicely for this final stretch of the
tournament now yeah it really is and the
drama does continue tomorrow chat Robert
David myself we will be back with all of
you to take you through the action as
the players fight to get that final spot
to challenge Magnus Carlson in the Chess
Masters Grand Final it's going to be a
big day of Chess we'll be back we'll see
you then it's been fun it's a good night
from
[Music]
us so y he's got his face in his hands
right now
David
think we see a minute down maybe soon
form down yeah I will take FIA here all
day
[Music]
long
oh
[Music]
come
sh
[Music]
oh